bien si vous le voulez bien nous allons
nous allons commencer madame la ministre
monsieur rapporteur général mes chers
collègues donc les contrats d'agenda du
gouvernement s'est exprimé là-dessus
nous conduisent à nous réunir
aujourd'hui dans une configuration et un
horaire inédit pour tenir le débat
sénatorial qu'il est d'usage d'organiser
avant chaque réunion ordinaire du
Conseil européen
l'essentiel est que ce débat ait lieu
est en effet fondamental surtout dans
les orgres graves que nous traversons
madame la ministre de pouvoir échanger
avec vous en amont des décisions
engageantes que les États membres vont
devoir prendre lors du prochain conseil
des 21 des 20 et 21 octobre les
événements se précipitent si bien que
les chefs d'État ou de gouvernement des
27 ont déjà eu besoin de se réunir
vendredi dernier à Prague ils ont
partagé le même diagnostic sur
l'utilisation de l'art énergétique par
la Russie qualifiée de missiles
tirer sur le continent européen par le
président du Conseil européen Charles
Michel ils ont aussi partagé une
ambition commune de faire baisser les
prix des ressources énergétiques qui ont
un impact considérable sur l'économie
européenne mais ils ont constaté aussi
leur division sur les moyens d'y
remédier alors qu'il y a urgence à
trouver des compromis pour alléger
concrètement le fardeau des citoyens et
entreprises de l'Union européenne sans
attendre l'Allemagne a déjà annoncé il y
a une dizaine de jours un plan de 200
milliards d'euros pour protéger son
économie contre la hausse des prix de
l'énergie une forme de bouclier
antimissiles nationales et non européen
le président Macron s’est engagé à
convaincre les autres Européens et donc
à surmonter certaines des resticences
allemandes sur un mécanisme de
plafonnement commun des prix du gaz
servant à produire de l'électricité tout
en prévoyant des mécanismes de
financement solidaire européen
préservant l'unité du marché unique ce
travail de conviction a-t-il déjà
commencé à produire ses fruits mesdames
la ministre c'est une question j'ajoute
à cela que nous n'avons pas en Europe à
pallier aux erreurs stratégiques
énergétiques des autres États
le plafonnement déprime ne risque-t-il
pas de priver l'Union
d'approvisionnement en gaz donc elle
mesure peut-on espérer trouver une bonne
réponse commune à la crise énergétique
qui fera plus union
deuxième enjeu décisif du prochain
sommet l'Ukraine alors même que l'Union
vient de convenir d'un huitième train de
sanction nous vivons depuis hier une
escalade du conflit ne parvenant pas à
prendre l'avantage après 7 mois de
guerre et défiée par la destruction du
pont de Crimée la Russie procède
désormais à des bombardements aveugles
qui s'apparente à des crimes de guerre
et la Biélorussie menace encore ce matin
d'ouvrir un front en désignant la
Pologne la Lituanie et l'Ukraine quelle
mesure l'Union européenne peut-elle
prendre pour arrêter ce triste massacre
les nouvelles livraisons d'armes
envisagées sont-elles la seule réponse à
apporter
troisième sujet collatéral la communauté
politique européenne qui a vu le jour à
Prague jeudi dernier et réuni 17 États
en plus des 27 dont les trajectoires
diffèrent radicalement Norvège
Ukraine Suisse Turquie Royaume-Uni
Serbie Azerbaïdjan que peut-on espérer
de cette nouvelle enceinte
le président Macron l'avait présenté
comme une communauté politique
c'est-à-dire une communauté de valeurs
certains des États participants diverses
clairement des valeurs de l'Union aussi
je m'interroge sur l'objet de cette
communauté qui aurait pu apparaître
comme une réponse à l'Organisation de
coopération de Shanghai récemment réunis
à l'initiative de Vladimir Poutine si
certains pays n'avaient pas participé à
ces deux rencontres pourriez-vous madame
la ministre nous éclairer sur la vision
française de l'avenir de la communauté
politique européenne après cette
première rencontre et je passe la parole
à notre rapporteur général du budget
Jean-François Husson
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
après les bouleversements induits par la
crise sanitaire apparue en 2020
2022 devait prolonger le retour à une
plus grande stabilité des finances
européennes amorcées dernière mais la
guerre en Ukraine et la crise
énergétique en ont décidé autrement à
tel point que plusieurs sujets largement
débattus au cours des mois écoulés sont
désormais relégués au second plan et je
pense par exemple et notamment à la
question des ressources propres de
l'Union
je vais j'ai choisi de concentrer mon
intervention sur la question énergétique
ça ne devrait pas vous surprendre et
plus précisément sur les réponses que
les États et l'Union peuvent apporter en
termes de soutien financier pour
traverser cette crise conformément aux
champs de ma fonction alors il y a moins
d'une semaine la Commission européenne a
proposé aux États membres
de mettre en place un plafonnement
temporaire des prix du gaz
pouvez-vous nous dire nous en dire
peut-être davantage madame la ministre
sachant par ailleurs que la présidente
de la Commission a présenté cette
proposition je vais la citer comme une
première étape vers une réforme
structurelle du marché d'électricité
pour atténuer les effets de cette crise
sur les agents économiques les membres
de l'Union ont tous mis en place des
réponses nationales jusqu'à l'annonce
par l'Allemagne d'un plan de soutien de
200 milliards d'euros jusqu'à ce qu'ils
viennent donc faire prendre conscience
du risque de fragmentation du marché
intérieur une réponse coordonnée à la
dégradation des contes des entreprises
les plus concernées par l'augmentation
de les prix de l'énergie et les risques
de réduction d'activités qu'elle induit
vous paraît-elle à ce stade et en l'état
possible enfin l'ensemble des pays
membres s'accorde sur l'objectif de
renforcer l'autonomie stratégique de
l'Union en diversifiant ses sources
d'approvisionnement en énergie 20
milliards d'euros supplémentaires vont
être consacrés au volley REpower u
inclus dans l'enveloppe financière du
fond pour la relance et la résilience en
vue d'aider les États membres à faire
face aux chocs créé par la crise la
hausse pardon vertigineuse des prix du
gaz et plus largement à la crise des
prix de l'énergie
pouvez-vous madame la ministre nous
donner davantage de précision sur leur
répartition je vous remercie
madame la ministre nous voulait sur la
parole puis ensuite chaque chaque groupe
avec son représentant désigné prendre la
parole pour 5 minutes et puis on vous
laissera répondre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la vice-président monsieur le
vice-président monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs
c'était évidemment un grand honneur de
me retrouver devant vous ce matin avant
de vous présenter comme de coutume
avant chaque Conseil européen les
principaux sujets qui vont y être
traités comme vous le savez c'est pour
moi le premier de ces exercices et il se
nourrit cette fois naturellement des
résultats du Conseil européen informel
de vendredi dernier ainsi que des leçons
que nous pouvons tirer de la première
réunion de la communauté politique
européenne comme vous les mentionnez
monsieur le président
la présidente check a souhaité réunir
les chefs d'État et de gouvernement deux
fois en octobre en raison des trois
chocs majeurs auxquels nous cherchons
ensemble les réponses les plus
appropriées il y a bien sûr la guerre en
crâne que vous avez mentionné la crise
énergétique et enfin la situation
économique puisque ces deux dernières
questions sont évidemment
intrinsèquement liés par ailleurs je
vais faire je vais prendre des
précautions puisque comme vous le savez
la situation évolue tous les jours et
donc ce que je vais partager avec vous
nos positions en amont du conseil mais
vous me pardonnerez celle-ci sont
évidemment susceptibles d'évoluer à
l'aune des événements que vous
connaissez et des concertations qui sont
conduites entre en européen
je vais commencer par l'agression russe
à l'encontre de l'Ukraine qui sera
évidemment au coeur des échanges du
Conseil européen ainsi que la question
de la poursuite de notre soutien à
l'Ukraine
et le président de la République l'a
indiqué hier suite à son échange avec le
président Zena ski notre soutien à
l'Ukraine et notre détermination à
l'aider à défendre sa souveraineté et
son intégrité territoriale sont
inchangés donc nous allons poursuivre et
intensifier le soutien politique
humanitaire économique et militaire
déjà à la fin du mois de septembre
l'Union européenne avait répondu
immédiatement au simulacre de référendum
qui se sont tenus dans les territoires
occupés en allant plus loin en matière
de sanction maintenant hier avec les
bombardements de plusieurs villes
ukrainiennes par la Russie c'est une
escalade et même c'est un changement de
nature de conflit puisque ces frappes
vissent des infrastructures civiles
elles sont donc une volonté délibérée de
la Russie de frapper la population
ukrainienne et comme l'a dit la ministre
Colona hier ces actes sont constitutifs
de crimes de guerre et la Russie devra
rendre compte
nous dans ce contexte évidemment l'Union
européenne va maintenir sa pression sur
le régime russe pour la faiblir et
l'affaiblir durablement
et cette pression passe par des
sanctions elle a un objectif clair c'est
d'affixier les corps de guerre russes
donc le nouveau paquet de sanctions qui
vient d'être adopté à 27 contient
plusieurs éléments qui vont resserrer
les taux sur le régime russe d'abord il
y a le mécanisme visant à plafonner le
prix d'achat du pétrole russe pour les
pays tiers qui va contribuer à réduire
les revenus énergétiques de la Russie
encore un peu plus tout en maintenant
une stabilité des marchés énergétiques
internationaux c'est important dans le
contexte comme vous le savez
mais ce n'est pas tout outre de
nouvelles mesures sectorielles qui sont
très ambitieuses sur l'acier ou sur les
produits chimiques outre la désignation
de 29 individus et cette entités ce
paquet prévoit également l'ajout d'un
critère qui va nous permettre de
sanctionner les individus et les entités
qui facilitent le contournement des
mesures on a donc un arsenal législatif
qui est vraiment très complet et qui va
avoir des résultats massifs qui en a
déjà d'ailleurs sur l'économie russe
comme vous si toujours les chiffres de
croissance je vais vous en donner un
autre cette fois-ci c'est la production
automobile qui est en Russie a chuté de
70% depuis août 2021
et évidemment ces sanctions peuvent être
renforcées à tout moment contre les
responsables russes contre la
Biélorussie si elle s'engage davantage
en soutien de cette agression
ensuite en parallèle évidemment nous
poursuivons le soutien à l'Ukraine dans
les différentes composantes que je
mentionnais sur le plan militaire
d'abord
au-delà de l'aide que vous connaissez
nous soutenons la création d'une mission
européenne d'assistance militaire afin
de répondre aux besoins de formation
d'armes ukrainiennes et nous espérons un
rapport à ce sujet au Conseil des
affaires étrangères du 17 octobre donc
la semaine prochaine
sur le plan financier la France soutient
également les efforts pour permettre à
décaissement rapide de la deuxième
tranche de l'aide macro-financière à
l'Ukraine et aussi entamer les
négociations sur la troisième tranche de
3 milliards ainsi que son déboursement
d'ici à la fin de l'année c'est
important c'est ce qui leur permet de
continuer à fonctionner
sur le plan politique
évidemment poursuivons notre soutien
perspective européenne de l'Ukraine et
ça ça a été très matériel avec la tenue
du premier sommet de la communauté
politique européenne à Prague au niveau
des chefs d'État et de gouvernement
cette communauté politique européenne
dont la seconde réunion se tiendra en
Moldavie permettra de nouer des liens
forts entre les pays du continent
européen candidats ou non candidats et
d'avancer sur des coopérations concrètes
puisque vous le savez le président en
acidité 7 à la fin de cette journée là
en fait sur le plan humanitaire la
Commission a annoncé hier la poursuite
de la facilité temporelle qui permet au
réfugiés ukrainien de vivre et
travailler dans les pays de l'Union
européenne jusqu'en 2024
et puis parce qu'il faut que nous
projetons et projetons le soutien à
l'Ukraine au-delà de la guerre c'est le
volet reconstruction qui doit nous
occuper dès maintenant vous le savez il
y a la conférence de Berlin le 25
octobre qui va immédiatement suivre le
Conseil européen et l'idée de cette
conférence et de progresser sur une
approche qui soit coordonnée des
différents types d'aides et en lien avec
les différents partenaires dont par
exemple les organisations
internationales
enfin pour
poursuivre avec avec l'Ukraine le
conseiller européen pourrait également
examiner le sujet de l'insécurité
alimentaire mondiale qui est causé par
la guerre de la Russie contre l'Ukraine
comme vous savez l'Union européenne a
mis en place des corridors de solidarité
qui ont permis de faire sortir du crâne
plus de 10 millions de tonnes de
céréales et puis nous avons consenti une
aide directe très importante au pays
vulnérable avec l'inacité l'initiative
pardon farm qui est portée par le
Président de la République qui doit
maintenant être déployé européen en lien
avec l'Union africaine et dans l'idée de
favoriser une sécurité alimentaire
soutenable dans le temps
et puis le Conseil européen va revenir
sur la question de l'accueil des
réfugiés russes depuis la déclaration de
la mobilisation partielle en Russie le
21 septembre si plusieurs centaines de
milliers de ressortissants
notamment vers l'Union européenne
alors ça a été moins de la force de
l'opposition à l'invasion russe en
Ukraine bien sûr au sein de la
population russe
et ce qui concerne mais ça pose des
questions à ce qui concerne le
traitement des demandes de visa de ces
ressortissants russes comme du statut
qui pourrait leur être reconnu et nous
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que les
États européens suivent à nouveau une
approche commune comme ça a été les
comme ça a été le cas depuis le début du
conflit nous voulons vraiment préserver
cet esprit d'unité
évidemment parler de l'Ukraine m'amène
immédiatement à la crise énergétique
et ce sujet sera abordé au Conseil
européen bien que comme vous le savez il
est déjà été beaucoup discuté vous
l'aurez un peu lié tous les deux tout à
l'heure
alors d'abord le Conseil européen doit
endosser les grandes thématiques
abordées lors du Conseil énergique
extraordinaire qui s'était tenu le 30
septembre
et des prêts lors des précédentes
réunions extraordinaires aussi des
ministres de l'énergie en juillet et
début septembre ces thématiques sont la
réduction de la demande d'électricité la
contribution temporaire de solidarité
des entreprises fossiles la mobilisation
des ressources pour soutenir les ménages
et les entreprises
le règlement que les ministres de
l'énergie ont adopté fin septembre va
permettre d'organiser la réduction de
notre consommation d'électricité il va
aussi faire contribuer les entreprises
du secteur de l'énergie à l'effort
collectif pour soutenir les ménages et
les entreprises dans cette période qui
est tout à fait inédite
bien évidemment nos entreprises les
citoyens ne peuvent pas supporter tout
seul le coût de la crise actuelle et
c'est pour cela que les États membres
les soutiendront et ça c'est l'objectif
des mécanismes de captation de la rente
des producteurs d'électricité et de la
contribution temporaire de solidarité
sur les entreprises du secteur des
énergies fossiles
ces mesures elles ont été décidées en
européen et elles seront déclinées en
France dans le projet de loi de finances
est-ce que c'est suffisant non nous
devons aller plus loin et nous devons
prendre et ce sera l'objet du Conseil
européen de nouvelles décisions qui vont
permettre de réduire immédiatement la
facture énergétique de nos concitoyens
et de nos entreprises
pour cela il y a différentes options
mais l'objectif c'est de mettre en place
un plafonnement des prix du gaz que ce
soit sur le gaz importé de Russie
directement sur les marchés de gros
l'utilisation d'une plateforme d'achat
commun va être un levier pour mettre en
oeuvre ce plafonnement ou peut être un
levier j'aurais dû dire et puis nous
nous souhaitons aussi faire baisser le
prix de l'électricité en européen en
subventionnant le gaz qui est utilisé
pour produire l'électricité sur le
modèle de ce qui a été mis en place dans
la péninsule ibérique
je crois que les Français comme les
citoyens comme les entreprises attendent
une réponse politique vraiment forte qui
soit coordonnées à la hauteur des enjeux
et donc nous allons continuer de mettre
un grand pression là dessus
et puis vous le savez la Russie pour
fuit l'instrumentalisation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'Union puisqu'elle réduit
continuellement ses livraisons de gaz
en fait je crois qu'on essaie depuis un
moment elle n'est plus un partenaire et
un fournisseur fiable
et nous le savons aussi c'est les
relations énergétiques maintenant vont
être pour toujours bouleversées par ces
agissements du Kremlin au cours des
derniers mois donc nous allons soutenir
sans ambiguïté aucune les initiatives et
les propositions de la Commission pour
nous préparer non seulement au mieux à
l'hiver prochain mais également au-delà
et donc ça veut dire que la France
effectivement va continuer à soutenir
une réforme structurelle des marchés de
l'énergie pour parvenir un marché plus
cohérent et moins volatile la commission
c'est engager à soumettre des
propositions d'ici à la fin de l'année
et comme je sais que ces questions
étaient au cœur de vos réunions du
mercredi 27 juillet avant la suspension
parlementaire aussi des derniers mois et
que vous venez à nouveau de l'émotionner
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour en
rediscuter et vous et vous rendre compte
des avancées
ensuite le Conseil européen va revenir
sur la situation économique puisque les
instituts les inquiétudes qui sur la
flexion évidemment pèse non seulement
sur nos perspectives de croissance mais
aussi créer des inquiétudes chez nos
concitoyens alors sur les perspectives
de croissance l'activité a continué de
progresser au deuxième trimestre 2022
dans la plus bonne part des grands pays
européens et comme vous savez la
croissance de la zone euro est restée
très solide à 0,6% pour le trimestre
ceci dit en même temps l'inflation a
atteint en septembre un nouveau record
historique dans la zone euro A+ 10%
après plus neuf 1% en août
alors la situation est un peu différente
en France grâce aux mesures nationales
que nous avons collectivement adopté
puisque l'inflation s'établit à 6,2%
. il y a également eu de nombreuses
mesures pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
mais nous croyons de nouvelles mesures
sont nécessaires elles sont en certaines
sont en cours de déploiement notamment
un nouveau chèque énergie d'ici la fin
de l'année pour les foyers les plus
modestes et puis le bouclier tarifaire
va être renouvelé en 2023
vous le rappeliez tous nos partenaires
européens ont adopté des mesures
similaires
mais c'est bien normal tout le monde a
les mêmes soucis mais évidemment nous
devons veiller à ce que les mesures
nationales ne conduisent pas une finie à
une divergence économique de la zone
euro
et donc c'est très important que nous
agissions dans un cadre commun et c'est
vraiment le sens de la révision de
l'encadrement temporaire de crise pour
les aides d'État qui vise à soutenir les
économies à la suite de l'agression de
la Russie contre la rue Keren et que la
Commission vient de présenter
et puis cela a été un peu abordé
vendredi dernier évidemment il ne faut
pas exclure la nécessité d'une nouvelle
action économique commune au niveau
européen puisque tous les États membres
ne disposent pas des mêmes marges de
manœuvre
et ça c'était le sens de la proposition
de la Commission qui est baptisée
ripower in you et qui est actuellement
disposé en trilogue ce que la Commission
a annoncé c'est qu'elle pourrait
éventuellement faire de nouvelles
propositions pour que la part de
subvention de ce paquet financier soit
augmentée
enfin je crois que les différentes
crises que nous avons connues ces
dernières années a été moins de la
nécessité de réviser notre modèle de
gouvernance économique sur le long terme
et comme vous savez la Commission
européenne devrait présenter d'ici à la
fin du mois c'est recommandations pour
réformer le pack de stabilité et de
croissance
évidemment elles vont nourrir les débats
entre États membres et nous au conseil
et le président au Conseil européen
rappellera la position française qui est
que nous avons besoin d'un cadre commun
évidemment solide qui permettent
d'assurer la viabilité des finances
publiques mais aussi de soutenir la
croissance et de répondre aux besoins
d'investissement notamment pour
renforcer l'autonomie européenne
dans le même temps il y a une différence
notable avec la tradition jusqu'à
présent nous demandons que la mise en
oeuvre de ses règles tiennent compte des
spécificités de chaque pays afin de
permettre une plus grande appropriation
nationale des règles
à cette fin comment on ferait ça les
États membres pourraient s'engager dans
un dialogue actif avec la Commission et
le Conseil pour définir la trajectoire
budgétaire la plus appropriée
nationalement ça permettrait de
renforcer l'engagement de chaque État et
donc de rendre notre cadre commun plus
efficace
en matière de relations extérieures
enfin pour conclure nous aurons un
échange sur les relations entre l'Union
européenne et la Chine
comme vous le savez l'Union européenne a
défini son approche des relations avec
la Chine en 2019 autour du triptyque
partenariat coopération rivalité
systémique
ce triptyque reste pertinent mais
l'évolution du comportement de la Chine
ces deux dernières années des notes tout
de même un glissement graduel vers une
dimension de rivalité qui est plus
affirmée c'est pour cela que nous avons
besoin de se débat stratégique renouvelé
donc la réponse européenne doit être
adaptée s'adaptée à ces changements
structurels que que l'on voit
dernièrement dans la relation
usine et de quoi je parle je parle de la
position chinoise sur la guerre en
Ukraine de la montée des tensions dans
le détroit de Taïwan
je crois aussi que l'Union européenne
doit accélérer ses efforts pour
rééquilibrer la relation économique
mettre en oeuvre davantage de
réciprocité
renforcer les outils de défense
commerciaux et poursuivre la
diversification de nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement pour limiter nos
vulnérabilités
ceci étant dit la Chine reste un
partenaire de coopération indispensable
sur certains enjeux globaux et
multilatéraux comme la lutte contre le
changement climatique nous ne l'avons
pas sans elle la protection de la
biodiversité ou encore la sécurité
alimentaire et la santé mondiale et donc
dans ces domaines nous allons devoir
poursuivre les coopérations
enfin et je crois que c'est très
important nous allons maintenir une
approche européenne très ferme sur la
défense des valeurs et des droits de
l'homme et la publication de la
proposition de règlement de la
Commission qui est relatif à
l'interdiction des produits
issus du travail forcé sur le marché de
l'Union et un développement très
significatif à cet égard
voilà pour pour finir le Conseil
européen il durera longtemps reviendra
sur la préparation de plusieurs grandes
échéances internationales d'abord la
préparation de la COP 27 comme vous
savez elle est accueillie cette année
par l'Égypte du 6 au 18 novembre à
sharm-el-shake
le sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
continue à augmenter au niveau mondial
et évidemment les tensions sur les
marchés énergétiques menacent
l'intégrité des engagements climatiques
internationaux et c'est pour cela que
nous souhaitons que le conseiller
environnement adopte le 24 octobre
prochain des conclusions qui vont porter
un mandat ambitieux de négociation de
l'Union européenne à la cop27
il y aura également la en discussion au
Conseil la préparation du sommet entre
l'Union européenne et laséane qui aura
lieu comme vous le savez en décembre
l'azéane c'est cet espace stratégique
qui occupe une place centrale dans la
région adopacifique
et le sommet va être une étape cruciale
pour convaincre les pays de la sienne de
prendre une position qui soit plus
affirmée de condamnation de l'agression
russe
ça va être aussi également l'occasion de
mettre en oeuvre la stratégie UE pour la
coopération dans la dopacifique et puis
la stratégie Globo getaway sur la
connectivité et nous devons identifier
des projets phares y compris dans le
domaine des infrastructures de qualité
enfin lorsque nous allons discuter de ce
sujet il faudra également et ce sera la
position de la France rappeler la
question de la représentation de la
Birmanie qui ne devra en aucun cas être
présente à un niveau politique au
sommeil et nous souhaitons que la
position européenne de non
reconnaissance de la jungle soit
voilà vous le voyez monsieur le
Président Mesdames messenatrices
Messieurs et sénateurs c'est un
programme chargé pour ce conseil
européen il témoigne de l'énergie de
l'Union européenne pour faire face
ensemble aux conséquences de l'agression
russe contre l'Ukraine je viens de
présenter les principaux enjeux dans les
grandes lignes mais je me réjouis que
cette audition et je vous remercie
d'être là aussitôt ce matin nous
permettent d'entrer dans le détail des
débats qui vont avoir lieu la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup
merci Madame la Ministre alors j'ai
oublié de le préciser en préambule mais
cette août cette audition cette séquence
est filmée en direct sur le site du
Sénat je vais donc laisser maintenant la
parole au groupe alors on est dans les
mains la même configuration que si on
était en séance c'est-à-dire 5 minutes
de prise de parole par groupe je vous
demanderai quand même de respecter votre
temps de parole pas une ou deux secondes
près mais en tout cas
soyez soyez attentif à ça puisque ça
fait 40 minutes globalement pour pour
les groupes si on veut laisser le temps
à Madame la Ministre de répondre et
ensuite les uns et les autres de vaquer
à nos occupations entre autres nos
réunions de groupe voilà ça nécessite
une certaine vigilance dans les temps de
prise de parole donc on va commencer par
le groupe LR et donc Cyril pelvat à la
parole pour 5 minutes merci monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre et mes
chers collègues vous l'avez rappelé le
prochain Conseil européen reviendra
naturellement sur la guerre du crâne
les succès militaires engrangé depuis un
mois par les forces ukrainiennes
renferent renverse le rapport de force
sur le théâtre d'opération il démonte
bien sûr la compétence elle courage les
armées ukrainiennes mais aussi
l'efficacité du soutien que le rapporte
les nations occidentales en matière
d'armement de renseignements de
formation et de planification alors que
l'Ukraine connaît sur le terrain une
dynamique positive qui lui permettra
espérons-le de retrouver sa pleine
souveraineté notre appui ne doit pas ne
doit pas faiblir et vous nous avez
rassuré sur ce point à ce titre et alors
que les États-Unis ont encore intensifié
leur aide militaire pouvez-vous nous
préciser si une nouvelle mobilisation de
la facilité européenne pour la paix est
à ce stade envisagé
d'autant que face au revers qu'il subit
Vladimir Poutine ne choisit pas pour
leur la voix de la désescalade mais
celle de la fuite en avant le chantage
nucléaire la mobilisation partielle et
les simulacres de référendum ainsi que
les annexions de terre ukrainiennes qui
sont sont suivis en sont la
manifestation en conséquence le Conseil
vient d'adopter un huitième paquet de
sanction vous l'avez rappelé il contient
notamment un plafonnement du prix du
pétrole russe transporté par les navires
européens vers les pays tiers des voix
se sont élevées je pense par exemple à
celle du PDG de Total Patrick pouyanais
pour dénoncer les effets
contre-productifs de la mesure dans un
contexte de réduction de la production
que vient de confirmer l'OPE et d'entrer
en vigueur imminente de l'embargo
européen sur le pétrole russe acheminé
par voie maritime pouvez-vous nous
préciser quels sont les anticipations du
gouvernement et des autorités
européennes sur les effets de cette
nouvelle sanction d'un point de vue
strictement politique cet accord a été
obtenu difficilement mais l'essentiel
était néanmoins qu'il soit obtenu car il
est primordial que l'Europe présente un
front uni à l'approche d'un hiver qui
sera nécessairement compliqué à gérer au
niveau énergétique donc économique et
social et donc politique
le gros thon est probablement encore
devant nous il faut donc l'aborder en
renféré mais cette exigence d'unité pour
faire face aux enjeux immédiats ne doit
pas nous empêcher de regarder avec
lucidité ceux du long terme l'Europe est
une crise de sécurité énergétique dans
le sens où l'offre risque de s'avérer
insuffisante pour couvrir la demande
c'est tout le sens des plans d'urgence
et des plans de sobriété que les États
membres ont établi sous coordination
européenne
tendentiellement avec l'abandon des
énergies fossiles et l'électrification
de nos systèmes énergétiques la
compression de la demande en électricité
n'est pas tenable il faudra bien en
passer par un accroissement de l'offre
l'énergie nucléaire sera donc un quad
qu'on en pense incontournable elle a été
dans le passé avec euratum l'un des
piliers de la construction européenne
elle est aujourd'hui largement absente
des réflexions sur la transition et la
sécurité en énergie du continent et fait
l'objet d'un travail de sable constant
il est donc grand temps de regarder la
réalité en face et de réengager un débat
de fond sur l'ordre de sécurité
énergétique de l'Europe
toujours au chapitre énergétique le
Conseil adopté le 30 septembre des
mesures d'urgence misant notamment un
taxer les super profits des entreprises
du secteur des énergies fossiles et à
plafonner les prix de l'électricité des
producteurs dit un frein marginaux
sur ce dernier point le texte adopté
contient un article concernant une
potentiel répartition entre État membre
du produit du plafonnement si j'ai bien
compris ce dispositif il prévoit que
lorsque les importations nettes
d'électricité d'un État membre qui était
en 2021
= ou supérieur à sa production
intérieure un accord de partage de
recettes devra alors obligatoirement
être conclu au plus tard le 1er décembre
2022 entre cet état et son principal
pays fournisseur pourriez-vous nous
préciser si la France sera concernée par
l'application de ce mécanisme c'est
longtemps l'activer de manière
optionnelle et enfin nous en dire plus
sur les principes généraux qui régiront
l'exécution de ces contrats
pourriez-vous par ailleurs nous faire un
état des lieux de l'avancée des travaux
concernant la réforme du marché de
l'électricité enfin du moins la
compléter dossier sur lesquels les États
membres ont eu l'occasion d'exprimer de
profondes divergence le scénarios d'un
découplage d'un des prix d'électricité
de ceux du gaz récemment avancé par
Ursula wanderline se confirme-t-il
pensez-vous que les États membres
réussiront rapidement à se mettre
d'accord au garde l'urgence de la
situation les nombreuses de nombreux
entreprises seront mises en grande
difficulté ces prochains mois faut d'une
réforme permettant de faire baisser le
prix du mégawattheure et ce même si le
bénéficient des aides de l'État et du
plafonnement des prix pratiqués par les
producteurs infras marginaux je pense
tout particulièrement aux stations de
ski dans tous les espoirs reposent sur
cette réforme qui sera le seul moyen
pour qu'elle puisse maintenir leur
activité sans être déficitaire je vous
remercie
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre je voudrais commencer mon
intervention en marquant notre
solidarité avec le peuple craignant qui
fait face à l'agression russe et qui
depuis donc six mois vit des crimes de
guerre de plus en plus documenté et
depuis hier fait face à des attaques
terroristes massives
son territoire défend il défendent les
ukrainien à défendre leur droit à
l'existence sur leur propre territoire
mais aussi leurs droits
d'autodétermination vous l'avez dit nous
avons besoin d'être solidaire au maximum
avec eux
quelle question si quel aide
pouvons-nous leur apporter si les
infrastructures vitales en matière
d'électricité et d'eau sont détruites au
cours des prochaines semaines
comment renforcer notre aide pour mieux
la coordonner je pense en particulier à
la reconstruction que vous avez évoqué
comment mieux coordonner notre aide
humanitaire je pense en particulier à ce
aux personnes qui sont visées par les
attaques et et aux soldats blessés
quand on parle d'énergie finalement on a
l'impression de revenir aux sources de
l'Union européenne et de du CK comment
avoir de l'énergie pas cher
et de manière solidaire et la question
est de savoir si en 70 ans nous avons
progressé
finalement l'urgence c'est de se sauver
cet hiver et il est important de trouver
des solutions qui soient finalement en
convergence avec le cours moyen terme
c'est-à-dire tenir nos objectifs
climatiques de ce point de vue là
la France et l'Allemagne même si ce sont
les deux grosses économies de l'Union
européenne ne sont pas des exemples pour
les autres parce que
nous avons des difficultés intrinsèques
en matière de production électrique en
France parce que l'Allemagne a construit
sa politique énergétique sur la
dépendance à l'énergie russe au gaz
russe comment arriver à reconstruire une
solidarité alors que les autres pays de
l'Union européenne ne regardent comme
étant défaillant
comment faire pour que le décalage qui
va s'exprimer actuellement entre les
moyens nationaux et monsieur le
Président évoqué les moyens allemands
qui vont être mis en oeuvre pour faire
face à la crise comment ne pas dé
comment ne pas avoir que ça comme
conséquence c'est-à-dire régulation des
marchés européens
enfin
comment peut-on imaginer construire une
dépendance demain de l'Europe à
l'Azerbaïdjan alors qu'on voit les
effets de la désher de la dépendance à
la Russie enfin sur le plus long terme
ne serait-il pas temps de s'interroger
sur des infrastructures en matière de
transport d'hydrogène et de capacité de
coopération avec les pays du Sud en
manière d'hydrogène solaire
sur la question sur les questions
économiques la guerre en Ukraine qui
engendre une baisse de l'euro fait
baisser la place de l'économie
européenne dans l'économie mondiale les
taux d'intérêt sont en train de monter
et le modèle et le moteur de le modèle
allemand et le moteur économique de
l'Union européenne et pour le coup remis
en cause comment dans ces conditions
nous assurer que nous allons pas vers
une grande crise financière à partir du
moment où la remise en les taux
d'intérêts qui sont de plus en plus
élevés risque de remettre en cause un
certain nombre d'actifs jusqu'à présent
considérés comme sur je pense en
particulier aux questions immobilières
et comment éviter à la fois comment
éviter les les une prise bancaire à
terme en matière de relations
extérieures je crois qu'il faut vraiment
avoir une vision sur les pays les pays
du Sud de la Méditerranée qui sont
aujourd'hui face à une crise alimentaire
et à une crise inflation très importante
il considère que ils sont victimes d'une
guerre qui n'est pas la leur
comment arriver à reconstruire ces
solidarités avec eux alors qu'ils sont
particulièrement aujourd'hui
critique vis-à-vis de notre politique de
visa nous sommes en train de détruire
une relation historique avec les pays du
Sud de la Méditerranée par des
humiliations successives relatives à nos
politiques de visa comment reconstruire
cette polie comme on reconstruire cette
solidarité à un moment où c'est
réellement important enfin Madame la
Ministre sur la question de la
communauté politique européenne monsieur
le président l'a évoqué déficit d'imager
une comité politique avec l'Azerbaïdjan
là encore qu'est-ce que ça signifie et
si cette
l'ensemble européen qui nous permet de
remettre pour des questions pour parler
de sécurité et de la Grande-Bretagne
très bien mais quelle utilité derrière
s'il y a rien de commun entre les pays
qui sont dans cette communauté politique
enfin madame la ministre je voudrais
évoquer trois sujets que vous n'avez pas
évoqué quelle solidarité avec les
combattantes de la liberté en Iran le
soutien aux droits de l'homme et celle
qui est celles et ceux qui crient femme
liberté en Iran qui nous touche au cœur
nous avons débattu de cela au Sénat la
semaine dernière l'Union européenne doit
être solidaire de ces de ce combat pour
la liberté enfin les résultats des
élections en Italie nous montre combien
si nous ne sommes pas solidaires avec
les pays de première entrée la question
de la progression de la droite de
l'extrême droite en Europe et du
populisme est totalement posé quel
solidarité enfin en conclusion monsieur
le Président je vois que vous mais je
voudrais enfin en conclusion
vraiment la question de l'État de droit
de l'indépendance de la justice en
Pologne de la lutte contre la corruption
Hongrie doivent rester malgré les
priorités que vous avez évoqué aussi à
l'ordre du jour et en conclusion je
voudrais saluer la contribution de
l'Union européenne à la découverte par
Bruno Le Maire de ce que ce sont des
supers profits
merci Jean-Yves Pierlot pour le groupe
Union centriste
madame la ministre merci monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues le 6
octobre dernier fut réunifié à Prague 44
chef d'État et de gouvernement pour la
première réunion de la communauté
politique européenne nouveau forum de
coopération à l'échelle européenne
filetée de cette instance avait au
départ nous réunir certains sceptifisme
de la part de nos partenaires européens
tous les états invités ont répondu
présent à ce titre nous pouvons dire que
se sommet est une réussite cependant
quelques doutes persistent quant à la
Via Vallier la viabilité de ce format la
taille de cette femme rhum risque de
constituer le premier obstacle pour la
prise de décision commune sans parler
des diversités politiques et culturelles
des pays qui la composent par exemple
Turquie et Grèce côte à côte quel fera
la composition finale de la communauté
comment s'établiront ses relations avec
l'Union européenne
la manière dont elle devrait pompier
décision a-t-elle été arrêtée cet organe
fera t-il doté d'un budget propre voici
un certain nombre de questions qu'on est
en droit de se poser aujourd'hui
lors du conseiller européen de fin
octobre sera évoqué la situation de
l'Ukraine ça déjà été largement évoqué
je crois qu'effectivement aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui même plus qu'avant-hier nous
devons être particulièrement inquiet et
cette question sur l'Ukraine me pose la
question de la défense européenne on se
rend compte aujourd'hui que la
contribution européenne en matière
d'armement et dérisoire par rapport aux
États-Unis et qu'il y a cette prise de
conscience mais qu'il devient sans doute
urgent de créer une véritable
coopération de défense européenne avec
des moyens financiers à la hauteur des
enjeux et on voit bien que même si
l'armée une partie de l'équipement russe
va se trouver détruit ils auront
capacité à reconstituer tout cela sans
doute assez rapidement dans les trois
années habillés à venir et quel sera la
position de l'Europe en matière de
défense européenne
directe de la guerre en Ukraine les
problèmes de la crise énergétique depuis
le choc pétrolier de 1970 c'est la plus
grave crise d'énergétique le
gouvernement comme un certain nombre de
pays européens dont l'Allemagne ont
engagé différentes mesures avec des
moyens financiers pour l'Allemagne très
important
et manuel Macron a appelé les élus à la
patience et à ne pas signer de contrat
d'énergie aujourd'hui estimant qu'il
ferait plus judicieux d'attendre l'issue
des discussions de Bruxelles qui auront
lieu au prochain Conseil européen nous
avons appris dans la presse qu'un accord
de bouclier tarifaire faisait son chemin
avec
l'accord de l'Allemagne aurons-nous
bientôt un accord et une décision
européenne sur le bouclier tarifaire des
énergies en fin dernier point mais qu'il
a aussi été évoqué le cas de l'Iran je
crois que la Communauté européenne doit
aux côtés de la France
montrer les dents et avoir des
représailles plus précises même si on
sent aujourd'hui un petit faiblissement
ou un début de concertation mais les
droits de l'homme les droits de la femme
en particulier doivent marquer les
valeurs de l'Europe unie et est-ce que
ce point sera évoqué lors du Conseil
européen du vin et 21 octobre voilà
monsieur le Président j'ai essayé de
faire vite merci en évitant de répéter
ce qui a déjà été dit c'est parfait
André gatolin pour le groupe RDPI oui
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues quand je
regarde des points affichés à l'ordre du
jour du prochain conseil guerre en
Ukraine stratégie énergétique relation
avec la Chine je ne peux m'empêcher de
penser que l'Europe est aujourd'hui
peut-être en train de changer de
paradigme jusqu'à peu en effet les
thèmes abordés lors des conseils
renvoyait de manière quasi obsession à
la construction du marché unique et à
ses politiques sectorielles dérivés les
questions de nature géopolitique quand
elles étaient à l'ordre du jour
apparaissaient généralement en fin de
menu et ne faisait l'objet que d'un
rapide tour de table pour constater nos
divergences en parler c'était comme acti
que notre continent n'était plus depuis
des décennies les pissantes du monde
alors oui la guerre en Ukraine reballe
les cartes d'une Europe presque
entièrement dédié à la production de
normes de standards de directives de
réglement très technique visant à mettre
en oeuvre les fameuses Cats liberté
supposées par ruissellement à coucher
d'une Europe toujours plus étroite
dans un discours assez prémonitoires de
janvier 1989 devant le Parlement
européen Jacques Delors prévenait on ne
tombe pas amoureux d'un grand marché
mais durant les années qui suivirent la
fin de la guerre froide nous avons
navement vous lui croire à la fin de
l'histoire à l'émergence d'un monde sans
ennemi à la transition démocratique
universelle grâce à l'ouverture des
marchés et au développement des échanges
commerciaux l'effondrement de l'URSS à
certes ouvert la voie à deux grandes
vagues d'élargissement celle de 1995
avec l'entrée de trois pays Finlande
Suède et Autriche jusqu'à lors contraint
à la neutralité puis celle de 2004 2017
qui a ouvert les portes au pays libérés
du jour soviétique mais dans notre
fleurie naïve de l'époque nous ne savons
émis les attendus géopolitiques qui
animaient ces pays en quelque sorte nous
avons failli nous n'avons pas proposé de
pacte commun la défense européenne pire
nous avons massivement désarmé comme en
témoigne le long déclin de nos
investissements militaires résultat les
expéis de l'Est se sont empressés
d'adhérer à l'OTAN avant de rejoindre
l'Union européenne ne voyant en
celles-ci comme instrument de
libéralisation et de rattrapage de leurs
économies nous avons persisté dans notre
fascination en amoureux pour le
consensus de Washington selon lequel le
marché accoucherait mécaniquement de la
démocratie et de la paix mondiale et
cela bien après que les États-Unis
eurent cessé d'y croire ces 10 dernières
années nous avons refusé de voir les
signes avant-coureurs de la dérive
autoritaire et belliqueuse du pouvoir
russe nous avons ignoré les alertes
venus de nos alliés voyons en leur
crainte une névrose obsessionnelle est
passéiste nous devons aujourd'hui à
l'est de l'Europe admettre que nous
avons admettre la terrible cécité dont
nous avons été à la fois les victimes et
les responsables dans après nous avons
privilégié l'impératif économique à
l'impératif de sécurité l'Allemagne
forte de sa puissance économique et
commerciale a été le moteur européen de
notre aveuglement collectif elle a
notamment été au cœur des choix
énergétiques qui nous ont rendu
dépendant du gaz russe avec la
construction de North stream 2 contre la
vie et les intérêts des pays de l'est et
du nord-est de l'Europe à un an près un
an après la fin du long règne dans Gala
Merkel son bilan apparaît aujourd'hui
bien bien moins resplendissant qu'à
l'époque ni il ne faut pas toutefois et
il sera juste de l'oublier la lourde
responsabilité de son prédécesseur
monsieur guérarch Ruder ni le fait que
nous avons nous aussi français parfois
accepter des compromis qui apparaissent
aujourd'hui des plus discutables en mars
2016 nous nous sommes ici au Sénat
fermement opposés à la proposition de
décision du Parlement européen et du
Conseil au nom de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de l'Union
européenne en gaz naturel qui voulait
obliger les États membres à soumettre
excenté à la Commission pour évaluation
et suivie tous leurs projets d'accord un
gouvernementaux ou modifications
avec des États non membres de l'Union la
liste de nos erreurs et de nos errements
stratégiques au nom d'une sacrose sainte
souveraineté nationale masquant souvent
une internationalisation non contrôlée
des échanges serait ici fastidieuses à
énumérer au regard des défis infinis que
nous devons désormais affronter alors
oui il faut saluer ici le réveil
géopolitique même s'il est encore tardif
et embryonnaire de l'Union il faut aussi
saluer le changement de cas présent de
l'Allemagne il faut aussi saluer le fait
qu'en dépit des railleries préférées à
l'époque c'est notre pays qui en 2017 a
osé porter publiquement la question de
la souveraineté européenne mais foin
d'auto célébration nous ne sommes encore
loin du milieu du guet et le réveil
géopolitique de l'Europe reste entouré
de nombreuses incertitudes il appellera
encore bien des efforts que nos états et
nous concitoyens n'accepteront que s'ils
ont conscience que sauver reconstruire
l'Ukraine c'est d'abord sauver notre
futur le futur futur de l'Europe je vous
remercie
merci André Joël guerriot pour le groupe
Les Indépendants républiques des
territoires merci président madame la
ministre alors qu'on sort d'une réunion
informelle du Conseil européen que c'est
tenu vendredi à Prague les dossiers à
l'ordre du jour donc du Conseil européen
des 20 et 20 octobre reste inchangés à
la crise ukrainienne vient se greffer
une nouvelle crise d'accentuée par la
première vous l'avez rappelé c'est celle
de l'énergie nous ne connaissons pas
encore la profondeur de cette dernière
mais déjà nos territoires et citoyens
font face à une première vague de
conséquences
les réponses apportées par les Européens
au conflits Ukrainiens nous au nord et
je me rappelle de la première réunion
qui s'est tenue deux jours après le
conflit ici au Sénat et j'avais pu
constater à quel point il y avait une
unanimité parmi nous et tous les pays
qui intervenaient de manière spontanée
aller dans la même direction ce qui
était pour nous tous un bel un beau
présage de solidarité européenne mais
cette guerre nous plonge également en
face à nous-mêmes et au lacune de notre
système énergétique vous avez et vous
avez évoqué un instant l'idée d'une
plateforme d'achat mais encore
faudra-t-il que nous mettions d'accord
quant à la chaîne d'approvisionnement ça
sera à mon sens un écueil pas facile à
régler la guerre en Ukraine exacerbe ce
qui était latent et que nous n'avions
donc pas réglé dans le passé
le marché intérieur européen d’énergie
inachevé et surtout à réorienter s'il
est dispositions que nous prenons
actuellement semblent aller dans le bon
sens une réflexion très profonde est
amenée ce qui ressort de la réunion de
Prague est intéressante à bien des
égards et d'abord sur le fait que les
accords restent difficiles à trouver ce
sommet était considéré comme une sorte
de préconseille européen les points
essentiels tels que le plateformement du
prix du gaz ou encore des aides
financières ont été évoquées force de
constater qu'il reste du travail
effectué pour se mettre d'accord avant
le 20 octobre prochain en tant
qu'observateur nous voyons quelques
lignes se dessiner avec une Allemagne
que l'on pourrait croire s'éloigner de
la solidarité qui incombe à l'Europe
quand la France conduit l'Europe le
dessin de l'Europe elle pensait l'Europe
et quand l'Allemagne conduit le destin
de l'Europe on a l'impression qu'elle
pense plutôt Allemagne Madame le
Ministre cuite du promoteur
franco-allemand dans cette nouvelle
crise les deux pays avaient réussi à
entraîner l'Europe avec d'importants
progrès et des textes nécessaires lors
de la pandémie covid-19 sommes-nous
aujourd'hui si éloignés quels sont les
derniers obstacles à un accord
comme je disais ces réponses devront
être accompagnées d'une réflexion plus
profonde la structure de notre système
est à revoir nous devons faire de cette
crise un point de départ vers les
transitions que nous nous sommes
nous-mêmes fixées je pense surtout aux
aides et prêt qui pourrait être accordé
il faut qu'il servent à réformer notre
système tout en préservant nos acquis
malgré de volonté de dépendance et de
souveraineté face au reste du globe nous
européen reste encore trop exposés au
tumulte du monde avec la nécessité de
renforcer nos solidarités
très concrètement nos citoyens souffrent
de la crise énergétique il en va de même
de nos collectivités quant aux
entreprises elles sont fortement
exposées à un risque d'une perte de
compétitivité un tel choc pourrait
malheureusement être accompagné d'une
désindustrialisation massive
si les usines européennes venaient à
fermer à cause du prix de l'énergie mais
aussi d'une inflation galopante comment
saurions-nous capables de produire pour
répondre à nos besoins nous devons
apporter et notre solidarité économique
sera à ce moment-là encore plus affaibli
si nous n'avons plus d'engrais que les
prix de l'exploitation agricole
s'envolent faute d'approvisionnement
comment allons-nous répondre à la
demande nous devrons aussi là importer
et notre souveraineté alimentaire serait
affaibli
c'est les coûts de fonctionnement
deviennent beaucoup trop importants
comment nos collectivités s'en
sortiront-elles enfin comme les peuples
comment les peuples européens passeront
cet hiver et hiver prochain sur ce
dernier point madame la ministre
avons-nous des objectifs de stockage
ainsi que des exigences sur les origines
de nos approvisionnements pour l'hiver
2023 2024 enfin je terminerai sur le
volet de la défense il faut le politique
extérieure européenne plus ambitieuse je
l'ai appelé de mes vœux et à plusieurs
reprises notamment lors de la parution
de la boussole stratégique européenne
madame la ministre depuis presque huit
mois maintenant les lacunes de la
défense européenne apparaissent au grand
jour nos infrastructures ont été
touchées actes de sabotage ou non nous
devons prendre cela en compte nos
voisins russes menacent ouvertement le
ouvertement le monde d'une guerre
atomique en tant que puissant européenne
et surtout la seule puissance européenne
au sein de l'Union européenne la France
porte une lourde responsabilité
Madame le Ministre n'est-il pas temps de
renforcer la cohérence de la réponse
européenne et des politiques étrangères
des États membres notamment au sein des
instances internationales en ayant une
Europe qui parle d'une seule voix merci
Madame le Ministre merci Joël
Jean-Pierre corbiset pour le groupe RDSE
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues je
commencerai tout d'abord par saluer la
récente intervention de la présidente de
la Commission européenne sur l'état de
l'Union volontarisme la détermination
affichée par une armure cela van
derlione en faveur d'une Europe
solidaire et ferme dans la défense de
ses valeurs et bien entendu le seul cap
à tenir les défis que nous font face
sont nombreux énergétiques climatiques
économique et aujourd'hui la guerre à
nos portes il remplisse l'agenda du
prochain Conseil européen en particulier
de la situation en Ukraine naturellement
mon groupe réaffirme son soutien total
aux ukrainien qui font preuve d'un
courage exemplaire et clairement
inébranlable nous sommes également
soucieux des jeunes russes en rupture
avec leur régime il serait souhaitable
d'avoir rapidement une position commune
sur le sort de ceux qui veulent gagner
l'Europe ce matin même en revenant sur
Paris dans le TGV j'ai fait le voyage
avec le responsable de la sécurité d'un
grand groupe de cosmétiques français
mondialement connu qui me disait que
c'est directeurs des usines en Russie
étaient menacés par les autorités
militaires afin récupérer les fiches de
pointage et mieux enrôler immédiatement
les salariés au-delà du drame humain il
est clair que ce sont aussi la
démocratie l'esprit de liberté qui sont
visés c'est encore plus frappant la
lumière du dernier discours de Sergueï
lavrof à l'Halloween u puis de celui du
présent Poutine du 30 septembre dernier
dans ces conditions le maintien d'un
dialogue paraît compliqué dans les
dirigeants russes utilisent le conflit
ukrainien pour mieux pour fendre
l'Occident et ses valeurs si nous sommes
pas dupe quand leur volonté de camoufler
leurs échecs militaires cette violence
verbale dessine pour le moment une
impasse diplomatique pour ne rien
arranger le bombardement hier de
plusieurs villes ukrainiennes dont le
centre de Kiev en riposte à l'attaque du
pont de Crimée confirme ce
jusqu'au-boutisme russe madame la
ministre le président Poutine ne semble
pas avoir de lignes rouges sans jeu de
mots mais quelle est la nôtre face à
l'escalade qui se joue sous nos yeux en
attendant oui il faut renforcer les
sanctions contre la Russie et continuent
de fournir une aide militaire à
l'Ukraine je suis leirai toutefois que
pour la France cela signifie de nouveaux
prélèvements à venir sur son stock et
même sur ses contrats commerciaux comme
cela était décidé concernant les canons
prévus par le Danemark je crois qu'il
faut l'accepter il faudra cependant
aussi durant l'examen du projet de loi
de finance avoir des garanties quand on
maintient à terme de nos capacités
opérationnelles et des objectifs fixés
par la loi de programmation militaire je
reviens en principal effet collatéral du
conflit qui va peser de plus en plus
lourdement sur nos concitoyens vous
l'avez rappelé madame la ministre la
crise de l'énergie mobilise fortement
les institutions européennes mon groupe
s'inquiète des difficultés à afficher à
fond uni Berlin semble en faire cavalier
seul aujourd'hui la solidarité
européenne et une nouvelle fois mise à
l'épreuve doit-on regarder l'Allemagne
mettre en danger la zone euro par le
bouclier tarifaire elle vient de décider
à hauteur de 200 milliards d'euros afin
de lutter contre la flambée des prix mon
groupe est très ouvert à la question du
plafonnement du prix du gaz position que
le gouvernement soutient madame la
ministre bien avant la crise ukrainienne
le couplage du prix et les gaz faisait
débat il reste à déterminer le bon
indice qui à la fois le prix et
l'approvisionnement une équation
difficile à trouver je le concède
au-delà de l'urgence nous approuvons
aussi le principe d'une vaste réflexion
sur une réforme structurelle du marché
d'électricité c'est aussi le moment
d'accélérer toutes les politiques en
faveur des énergies renouvelables ce
n'est pas faute de le dire j'aurais
d'ailleurs comme vous beaucoup de mes
collègues ici présents l'occasion d'y
revenir en détail dans notre débat de
demain au Sénat regardons en tout cas de
près ce que fait l'Espagne qui apparaît
à juste titre comme le bon élève nous ne
prenons pas rapidement les bonnes
décisions dans un cadre commun la
question de l'énergie risque de
fragiliser une démocratie des jeux
éprouvés par une succession de crise je
vous remercie
merci Jean-Pierre Jacques ferrique pour
le groupe écologiste
monsieur le Président Madame ministre
chers collègues avec les crises
consécutives à l'invasion russe ce
Conseil européen s'inscrit dans un
contexte qui s'est durci durci dans un
sens contraire au
renforcement européen voire même aux
valeurs européennes le respect de l'État
de droit la protection des minorités et
la démocratie sont-ils encore des acquis
intangibles les replis nationalistes et
populistes montent face à la crise
énergétique les logiques nationales sont
de retour la régression menace la
construction européenne et la tenue des
objectifs écologiques pourtant limités
définies par le Green Deal monsieur le
rapporteur général la commission des
finances je viens d'évoquer à l'instant
le report au second plan de la mise en
place des ressources propres cela risque
fort à terme de contraindre l'Europe a
réduire la voilure de ces politiques
essentielles enfin parallèlement avec
l'inflation particulièrement la hausse
vertigineuse des coûts énergétiques
montrent les attentes les impatiences
des citoyens à les citoyennes des élus
locaux aussi impatience vis-à-vis des
politiques pour qu'ils apportent des
réponses à la hauteur face à ce nouveau
mur en quelque sorte après le mur de la
pandémie après celui de la reprise et de
la résilience après celui de la riposte
commune à la Russie face à ce nouveau
mur est-ce que nous allons dériver vers
on parlait de fragmentation tout à
l'heure vers une certaine dislocation
européenne allons-nous retomber dans les
Hermans du chacun pour soi et des
renoncements concernant l'énergie par
exemple les décisions que nous prenons
maintenant notamment sur les
infrastructures vont nous engager
longtemps je crois que la France comme
l'ensemble de ces députés européens à
l'exception évidemment du RN a raison de
s'opposer au projet de gazoduc mit cat
qui nous enfermerait dans la dépendance
au gaz pendant plusieurs décennies
encore ça prend ainsi nos objectifs de
décarbonation je crois qu'il faut
refuser une entorse majeure au principe
de non-financement des infrastructures
des énergies fossiles il renonçait
serait un précédent dans lequel se
précipiterait sans doute bien d'autres
États membres à dire l'Espagne et
l'Allemagne sur les prix de l'énergie à
la consommation il est également
urgent de les plafonner mais
intelligemment ce serait une erreur
d'opérer mécaniquement un simple
plafonnement avec une quantité de base
de 80% au coût plus accessible et les
20% restants bien plus cher on risque en
effet de pénaliser ainsi les ménages les
plus modestes votre collègue panier à
une hachée parlait de sobriété subies
l'impératif de justice sociale doit être
bien pris en compte sur le front du
climat avec le paquet fit for fifty-five
les trilogues doivent permettre
d'étendre le marché carbone européen au
bâtiment et au transport le Parlement
propose de limiter cette extension aux
usages commerciaux c'est en effet
raisonnable évitons une nouvelle crise
façon gilet jaune la fiscalité
environnementale ne peut pas peser
injustement sur les messages sur les
ménages populaires qui n'ont le plus
souvent pas le choix il semblerait
là-dessus que le trilogue d'hier né
selon les échos pas vraiment porté ses
fruits il a même été qualifié par
certains de perte de temps pouvons-nous
espérer de réels avancées pour le
prochain qui aura lieu je crois le 10
novembre dans les jours à venir vous
l'avez évoqué la Commission devrait
produire ses propositions de retour
voire de réformes des règles budgétaires
européennes suspendues il serait
désastreux je crois de suivre les
frugaux qui prônent le retour strict aux
critères antérieures nous avons besoin
d'une réforme de ces règles car le pacte
de stabilité du monde d'avant serait un
carcan qui compromettrait effectivement
les investissements d'avenir dans la
transition écologique la cohésion et la
justice sociale des compromis sont
possibles si la gouvernance européenne
arrive à sortir du strict quantitatif en
mettant du qualitatif environnemental et
social dans ces critères si pour fixer
le seuil d'endettement elle sait prendre
en compte l'amortissement des
investissements écologiques et sociaux
d'avenir
sur les atteintes à l'état de droit nous
souhaitons que le conseil soit actif ça
fait quatre ans déjà que la procédure de
l'article 7 est ouverte en attendant les
personnes LGBT sont la cible d'attaque
de plus en plus violente en Hongrie en
Pologne en attendant que deviennent les
valeurs européennes quand on Hongrie on
veut obliger les médecins à faire
écouter le battement du cœur du foetus
aux femmes souhaitant aborder sur les
droits humains les droits des femmes
particulièrement lieu doit peser autant
qu'elle le peut sur le régime iranien
enfin pour conclure un sujet me paraît
relevé des régressions qui menacent
celui de la méthode de pêche dite saine
d'emersal venue des Pays-Bas
essentiellement ce sont ces vastes
filets de pêche reliés à deux câbles
vibrants qui soulève les sédiments et
rabattre les poissons même les plus
petits raclantis mettant des zones
entières à blanc tuant la pêche mettant
en péril nos pécheurs artisanaux le
gouvernement français a balayé jeudi
dernier en trilogue l'amendement voté
par le Parlement européen qui donnait
l'opportunité d'interdire cette méthode
de pêche industrielle est-ce donc cette
industrialisation destructrice de la mer
que la France souhaite que reste-t-il de
la crédibilité du discours de qui se
positionnait fortement en faveur de la
protection des fonds marins
merci Jacques Pierre Laurent pour le
groupe CRCE
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
madame la ministre
le format un peu inhabituel de notre de
notre échange m'amène à être assez
direct dans les questions que je vais
vous poser plutôt que de faire une
intervention comme on en fait parfois
dans l'hémicycle on me concentrant sur
la question énergétique
qui est probablement une des questions
qui va continuer à secouer très
profondément toutes nos sociétés dans
les mois et dans les années à venir et
donc ce sera des questions sur les
mesures qui sont actuellement en
discussion d'abord une remarque sur les
super profits enfin ce que nous on
appelle les super profits ce que dans le
jargon européen on appelle aujourd'hui
donc la contribution solidaire sur les
entreprises qui travaillent dans les les
combustibles fossiles d'abord une
remarque c'est que une définition est
possible en tout cas la Commission
européenne s'emploie en définition on a
souvent entendu dans l'hémicycle ici
qu'une définition était impossible elle
semble possible même si je la trouve
très restrictive elle existe donc un
débat sur cette définition était et
reste possible
la décision de la
qui était envisagée au Conseil européen
permet ouvre la possibilité de taxer à
33%, les entreprises les entreprises
concernées donc ma question est assez
concrète
à quelles entreprises cette contribution
pourrait-elle s'appliquer en France
parce que j'imagine que les estimations
de la Commission européenne équitable
sur une recette de 25 milliards d'euros
ne sortent pas d'une d'un calcul qui est
d'une opération du Saint-Esprit mais sur
des évaluations précises donc sur une
liste d'entreprises concernées donc
quels sont les entreprises qui
pourraient être concernés en France par
cette taxe le gouvernement français le
visage-t-il d'utiliser cette possibilité
de taxation à 33% pour ces entreprises
et au total combien la France estime
qu'elle pourrait récupérer avec cette
contribution solidaire
sans ces éléments concrets évidemment il
est très difficile de juger pour nous de
la pertinence réelle de ce dispositif
deuxième série de questions qui concerne
la question énergétique de manière plus
globale et notamment la question de
du de la fixation des prix de gros
ma question elle est assez parce que
pour tout vous dire même en essayant de
suivre
attentivement toutes les décisions qui
sont prises on a parfois du mal à
comprendre
ces dispositifs et à comprendre leurs
effets réels sur un pays comme le nôtre
moi j'ai une question générale d'abord
c'est est-ce que la décorrélation des
prix du gaz et du marché gros
l'électricité reste véritablement à
l'ordre du jour parce que ça fait des
mois qu'on que Bruno Le Maire à chaque
fois compose la question nous dit mais
bien sûr c'est ça qu'il faut faire et
bien sûr c'est vers ça qu'il faut aller
mais à force de regarder les dispositifs
qui se mettent en place qui sont
excusez-moi du jeu de mots un peu des
usines à gaz
difficile à comprendre on se demande si
ces objectifs et bien sur la table et au
moins est-ce qu'il continue d'être porté
par la France dans ces discussions
concernant les dispositifs qui sont
envisagés qui sont donc dans l'hypothèse
ou cette perspective resterait sur la
table des dispositifs intermédiaires
d'où sort le chiffre de 180
euros du mégawattheure pourquoi ce
chiffre qui continue d'être extrêmement
élevé et très supérieur c'est pour ça
que je pose la question
au coût au coût de production en tout
cas concernant notre notre pays et qui
donc c'est un chiffre qui peut laisser
perdurer encore des systèmes de rente
indus
d'autant que la Commission européenne
prévoit qu'il puisse être dépassé que
les recettes des 10% de recettes
supplémentaires pourraient être ajoutés
à ce à ce prix fixé donc qu'en est-il
réellement qu'est-ce qu'on attend
précisément la France et quels sont les
objectifs que nous continuons à nous
fixer dans cette négociation enfin une
autre question concernant les prix du
gaz on parle du plafonnement du prix du
gaz au plan européen des corridors de
plafonnement
mais il y a une question très précise
est-ce que la fin des tarifs régulés du
gaz en juin 2023 est toujours sur la
table ça fait plusieurs fois qu'on pose
la question
et on a toujours pas la réponse à cette
question d'une manière générale sur
toutes ces questions moi je souhaiterais
que vous nous disiez avec précision ce
que porte la France
souvent on a le droit à des commentaires
sur l'état de la négociation européenne
mais sur quels objectifs précis se bat
la France dans toutes ses négociations
voilà je vous remercie madame la
ministre
merci Pierre donc Madame le Ministre à
vous de répondre au groupe et puis
ensuite nous aurons une petite séance
question-Réponses questions d'une minute
une minute 30 auquel vous pourrez
répondre
point par point merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci à mesdames et messieurs et
sénateurs je vais essayer de répondre à
toutes vos questions vous vous excuserez
mes rudes éventuelles et
certaines précisions que je peux bien
sûr donner après
en bilatéral monsieur le sénateurs vous
m'avez parlé et posé des questions sur
la facilité européenne pour la paix ou
plutôt sur les efforts de défense
et nous sommes cherché
et effectivement nous sommes en train de
de travailler là-dessus comme vous le
savez l'Union européenne avait mobilisé
de Virg 5 milliards d'euros pour
organiser la livraison d'armes à
l'Ukraine via cette facilité européenne
de la paix nous allons poursuivre ce
soutien dans la durée et le Haut
représentant a notamment appelé à ce
qu'elle soit cette facilité soit
augmentée d'une sixième tranche de 500
millions ce qui l'apporterait à 3
milliards et ça sera
à l'ordre du jour du Conseil des
Affaires étrangères du 17 octobre
vous m'avez ensuite posé des questions
sur les effets des
nouvelles sanctions d'abord je voudrais
rappeler que les effets des sanctions
sont dans la durée l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'action la capacité de la
Russie à mener ses agressions et donc ce
que ce que l'on fait c'est d'une part
son industrie d'autre part les personnes
qui facilitent la guerre sont en
responsabilité de guerre que ce soit les
nouveaux généraux que ce soit
ceux qui ont facilité les simulacres de
référendum ceux qui font de la
propagande et donc tout cela à nouveau
visa affecter à la fois sur le plan
militaire mais aussi du narratif
la Russie
à l'inverse j'aimerais qu'on rappelle et
peut-être c'est l'occasion ici que
les effets sur l'énergie ce n'est pas
nos sanctions c'est la Russie qui fait
le yoyo si vous me permettez
l'expression avec l'approvisionnement
d'énergie de façon effectivement à faire
monter les prix et à déstabiliser nos
sociétés et la réponse est multiple et
j'aurais l'occasion
d'y revenir mais elle vise pour nous à
d'une part assurer l'approvisionnement
en faisant baisser la consommation en
assurant les stocks en diversifiant les
capacités d'approvisionnement en
accélérant sur le renouvelable mais
aussi à faire des bougies en interne et
à agir en européen et je reviendrai
dessus puisque vous êtes plusieurs à
m'avoir posé cette question pour faire
baisser les prix effectivement
juste
sur l'accord de solidarité à ce propos
dont vous m'avez parlé qui est dans le
règlement sur l'énergie je vous
reviendrai en bilatérale là dessus
puisque ce sont des négociations qui
sont je crois
toujours en cours
et enfin et je reviendrai à nouveau la
du Sud vous avez soulevé la question du
différentiel d'énergie mixe entre les
pays c'est vrai nous nous avons besoin
de peu de gaz par rapport à d'autres
pays qui en ont besoin de plus et il ne
s'agit pas seulement de l'Allemagne mais
aussi de beaucoup de pays de l'est et du
sud-est de l'Europe ce qui effectivement
demande une grille énergétique qui soit
très opérationnelle sur le continent
pour qu'à court terme nous puissions
avoir ces mécanismes de solidarité un
moyen terme je crois que notre objectif
a tous il est commun c'est de sortir des
énergies fossiles ce qui nous assurera
notre sécurité énergétique
monsieur le sénateur
le compte vous m'avez également
interrogé sur
le soutien que nous apportions notamment
en ce qui concerne
les humanitaire et le soutien à
l'Ukraine alors il prend plusieurs
formes j'ai mentionné dans mon discours
à effectivement l'accueil des réfugiés
qui est important et qui risque de
d'augmenter avec la nouvelle vague de
frappe que l'Ukraine vient de vient de
souffrir
je voudrais aussi rapporter tout ce que
fait le ministère des Affaires
étrangères avec son centre de crise et
de soutien est-ce que font aussi les
collectivités territoriales le secteur
privé pour acheminer mille tonnes
d'humanitaire et de réhabilitation
d'urgence vous avez vu cette opération
un bateau sur l'Ukraine
nous nous sommes aussi concrètement
engagés pour répondre à l'urgence alors
que des infrastructures critiques ont
été frappées par les cils russes nous
participons également à la
reconstruction du crâne je l'ai
mentionné tout à l'heure mais aussi
identification
des exactions et des crimes de guerre en
fait qui sont commis par la Russie en
Ukraine donc c'est à la fois un soutien
humain militaire comme je l'ai mentionné
tout à l'heure mais aussi
humanitaire
vous m'avez parlé de la France et de
l'Allemagne
et des différentes stratégies de
polysémique comme je venais de le
mentionner au sénateur pelva je crois à
nouveau notre objectif est commun à
moyen terme il est sorti des énergies
fossiles et à court terme il est
effectivement de s'assurer que
l'ensemble de l'Union européenne puisse
non seulement être approvisionnés à être
approvisionné à des prix raisonnables
vous avez vu la fabrication rapide de
Méthanie les accord qui sont passées à
différents niveaux
je crois que on a on a tous et la
multiplication des conseils
extraordinaires de l'énergie le monde
absolument essayer de
s'assurer à la fois au niveau national
et au niveau européen et bien sûr il
faut faire les deux en parallèle
s'occuper de l'hiver et de l'hiver
prochain et prévoir le moins interne oui
nous demandons et nous l'avons demandé
Bruno Le Maire l'avait d'ailleurs
rappelé depuis je crois après de neuf
mois maintenant une réforme du marché de
l'électricité à terme qui est différent
du découplage de court terme sur lequel
je reviendrai et nous demandons aussi
d'accélérer la sortie des hydrocarbures
et d'ailleurs l'Europe a un objet qui a
relever l'ambition de son objectif
puisque nous allons baisser nos
émissions de 55%, pas d'ici à 2030 par
rapport
à
1990 vous m'avez également interrogé à
ce sujet
sur l'hydrogène
et je vous remercie de cette question
comme vous le savez nous voulons que la
France soit le leader de l'hydrogène des
carbonée et pour ça nous devons investir
massivement
donc la France a mobilisé 7 milliards
d'euros entre 2020 et 2030 ce sont des
investissements qui sont soutenus par
l'Europe puisque le plan de relance
européen engie va en couvrir 2 milliards
et au niveau européen nous allons avoir
plus de 5 milliards qui seront mobilisés
par le projet important d'intérêt commun
plus d'intérêts européens comme un plus
communément connu sous le nom de pieds
comme vous savez qui est sur l'hydrogène
juste pour mémoire la stratégie
nationale pour le développement
d'hydrogène de carbonée a été annoncée
en septembre 2020 comme j'ai dit il
s'agiter de milliards d'ici à 2030 et ce
qu'elle vit c'est le développement des
filières de l'électrolyse de la mobilité
lourde à l'hydrogène et évidemment de
contribuer ainsi à des carboner
l'industrie et les transports et je
pourrais vous donner plus de détails si
vous en voulez
vous avez également mentionné la
situation économique et la crise
économique et la crise
et les risques de crise financière avec
la remontée des taux je crois que juste
quelques points là-dessus effectivement
les taux remontent mais les taux ont été
exceptionnellement bas depuis la crise
souveraine de la zone euro et donc en
fait c'est là on ramène les taux à des
niveaux qui sont un peu plus en ligne
avec la moyenne historique vous avez
mentionné les risques immobiliers la
France bénéficie comme vous savez d'un
système où les taux sont fixes en
général dans l'immobilier ce qui est
effectivement est une protection par
rapport au pays où les taux sont
variables lorsque un ménage fait un
emprunt immobilier vous avez mentionné
les banques comme vous savez depuis la
crise financière de 2008 la
réglementation bancaire a été
considérablement renforcée et nos
banques sont beaucoup plus solides dans
l'Union européenne
vous m'avez ensuite interrogé sur la
communauté politique
européenne et je pense que c'est le
moment où il est probablement utile pour
moi de rappeler pour donner un peu de
sens concret je reviendrai sur d'autres
questions qui m'ont été posées les 7
projets concrets ou pistes de
coopération concrètes sur lesquelles les
membres de la communauté politique
européenne vont plancher pour la
deuxième réunion qui aura lieu en
Moldavie dans 6 mois c'est cette projet
sont la protection de nos
infrastructures essentielles donc sont
les gazoduc les gaz les câbles les
satellites on a vu à quel point c'était
important une stratégie pour mieux
lutter contre la cybercriminalité la
propagande et la désinformation je crois
que ça aussi c'est enfin tout est
vraiment essentiel mais ça en
particulier une stratégie en intégrée en
matière énergétique nous devons limiter
nos dépendances et réduire les prix
également pour nos pays voisins parce
que on aura les mêmes soucis sociaux et
politiques si cela se fait pas une
politique commune de la jeunesse et ça
pour le sentiment d'appartenance et
renforcer les coopérations entre nos
universités nos politiques éducatives
c'est renforcer une culture européenne
qui va dépasser les frontières
nationales
cinquièmement une politique intégrée en
matière de gestion des flux migratoires
d'accueil de lutte contre les réseaux de
passeurs qui sont des sujets d'intérêt
commun à beaucoup de des pays de la CPE
la mise en place d'un fond de
reconstruction pour l'Ukraine et puis
enfin des approches coordonnées sur les
grands sujets régionaux comme la mer
Noire la mer Baltique la mer du Nord ou
le Caucase
je crois que il y a un grand
enthousiasme des pays de la CPE
notamment on a vu beaucoup de
propositions pour tenir la prochaine
réunion si finalement la Moldavie qui le
fera ensuite l'Espagne et ensuite le
Royaume-Uni mais sa témoigne vraiment
d'un intérêt de travailler ensemble sur
ces sujets communs au-delà du politique
vous m'avez ensuite interroger sur
l'Iran et les manifestations
d'abord avec
permettez-moi de dire à quel point
vraiment le
cette répression est inhumaine et nous
touche avec toutes mes homologues
ministres des Affaires européennes ou
secrétaire d'État des affaires
européennes de l'Union européenne nous
avons signé un appel très très tôt au
début de cette de ces de ces violences
maintenant effectivement
dès le 19 septembre la France a condamné
ses violences et puis depuis 26 jours la
France continue d'être très active au
Conseil des droits de l'Homme à Genève
dans toutes les enceintes
internationales et nous le faisons dans
tous nos échanges bilatéraux et à tous
nos niveaux rappelons notamment que
l'Iran à souscrit au principe à des
principes fondamentaux notamment les
principes du pacte relatif aux droits
civils et politiques des Nations Unies
et nous leur demandons de évidemment les
respecter maintenant vous allez me dire
ce n'est pas suffisant et vous aurez
raison au niveau européen nous sommes en
train de finaliser des travaux pour
sanctionner les responsables de cette
répression ça va se traduire par des
gels d'avoine des interdictions de
voyager
et nous devrions avoir un accord en
début de semaine prochaine le 17 octobre
au Conseil des affaires étrangères
enfin vous vous êtes inquiété de l'État
de droit en Pologne et en Hongrie et là
aussi je voudrais vous dire que nous
nous continuons de devrait et d'être
vraiment très très rigoureux sur cet
État de droit nous aurons au Conseil des
affaires générales très bientôt une
audition de la Pologne et de ce qu'elle
a entrepris pour assurer l'indépendance
de sa justice et ensuite nous avons
donné à la Hongrie un petit peu plus de
temps pour mettre en oeuvre les
engagements qu'elle a pris en ce qui
concerne l'état de droit et notamment
les mesures anticorruption à nouveau
elle s'est engagée à faire des choses
l'engagement ne suffit pas nous voulons
voir cela mis en oeuvre nationalement et
c'est pour ça que nous lui avons quand
je dis nous Europe donner jusqu'au mois
de novembre avant de regarder ce qu'il y
avait été fait
monsieur le sénateur l'eau vous avez
continué effectivement à m'interroger
sur la communauté politique européenne
et notamment sa taille je voudrais vous
rassurer merci nous n'avons pas
l'idée est pas de prendre des décisions
à 44 tout le temps l'idée c'est
effectivement de favoriser le dialogue
et les projets d'intérêt commun mais ça
peut être ambilatéral entre bilatérale
ou en pluriel latéral mais qu'ensemble
nous trouvions des chemins pour ancrer
tous ces pays
à l'Union européenne et son état de
droit vous avez émotionné mais ça a été
très important de que cet espace puisse
aussi permettre un dialogue entre la
Turquie et la Grèce ou entre la Turquie
et Chypre de la même façon qu'il y a eu
un dialogue entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan qui comme vous le savez a
conduit à l'acideature d'un accord qui
permet l'envoi d'une mission européenne
pour observer et rapporter au Comité des
frontières ce qui était en train de va
passer entre l'Arménie et laserbaïdjan
en ce qui concerne le financement vous
avez raison s'il faut des projets
concrets nous aurons besoin de
financement tout n'est pas arrêté il y a
plusieurs choses qui sont à l'étude
d'abord il peut y avoir une contribution
des organisations internationales comme
c'est le cas dans le cadre du G7 ou du
G20 il peut effectivement on pourra
aussi s'appuyer sur des programmes
existants pour ne pas dupliquer et pour
ne pas manquer des choses et vous pouvez
penser aux partenariats oriental par
exemple ou à d'autres projets qui
existent aujourd'hui
vous m'avez ensuite interrogé sur
l'Europe de la défense d'abord ça fait
longtemps que je ne l'ai pas rappelé
mais dans les avancées de la présidence
française de l'Union européenne et il y
a effectivement un cadre cohérent et
ambition d'action de l'Union européenne
avec la boussole stratégique qui comme
vous le savez est le premier livre blanc
européen en matière
de sécurité je crois que c'est très
important parce que ça va définir à la
fois ce que nous pouvons faire sur le
moyen terme mais aussi donner des
orientations qui effectivement vont
avoir des effets sur le court terme sur
le court terme l'Europe est parvenue à
mobiliser les 2,5 milliards d'euros que
nous voulons augmenter à 3 milliards
comme je disais pour la livraison
d'armes
à l'Ukraine mais avec cette boussole et
d'autres et les autres actions de
l'Union européenne nous allons aussi
nous allons aussi permettre d'encourager
les investissements de défense et de
rationaliser les différents engagements
qui sont pris séparément par les
nombreux États membres une question que
m'a également posé je crois monsieur
aussi sénateur gâteau lin et Monsieur
dessinateur guerriot
vraiment il y a une volonté de fournir
de l'aide et de la formation des
personnes de permettre des augmentations
de capacité des achats de munitions et
pour l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
européenne puisque
nous avons donné mais beaucoup de petits
pays ont aussi beaucoup donné à
l'Ukraine et donc l'idée c'est
effectivement de reconstituer des
capacités dans le court terme pour
continuer de soutenir à l'Ukraine mais
aussi de se permettre un moyen terme
d'être plus efficace plus rapide et
d'avoir des instruments différents et
enfin
et je crois que c'est le souci tout le
monde et je voudrais juste le rappeler
ce n'est pas de la concurrence à l'OTAN
c'est une articulation avec le temps et
quand on travaillera
quand nous travaillons tous les deux en
bon articulation les deux institutions
je crois que nous sommes beaucoup plus
forts et beaucoup plus efficace
monsieur listen acteur vous avez
mentionné l'énergie et notamment les
recommandations du président qui ont
très comme vous le savez parce que les
prix de marché immédiat sont plus élevés
que les prix futurs donc effectivement
il faut pas se caler sur les prix de
marché immédiat et notre objectif c'est
de faire baisser les prix de l'énergie
je crois que
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai oublié une question
sur les visages j'y reviendrai je vous
prie de m'excuser
des trucs de faire baisser les prix de
l'énergie et c'est vraiment la direction
dans laquelle que prend le Conseil
européen laissez moi juste vous rappeler
que la présidente check a dit qu'elle
réunirait autant de conseils énergies
extraordinaires que nécessaire pour
arriver à cet objectif j'espère que nous
aurons quelque chose pour le 20 21
octobre mais je suis confiante que nous
aurons quelque chose
de toute façon dans ces mesures et comme
je
lui disais tout à l'heure il y a à la
fois la réduction de la demande
je voudrais répéter que c'est important
parce que si on enlève de la pression
sur la demande avec une offre constante
pardonnée économiste qui est en moi mais
ça fait baisser les prix et notamment
les prix de marché puisque le signal est
et tout de suite perçu par par les
acteurs de marché donc ça c'est la
première chose baisser la consommation
et les stockages en tout ce qui concerne
la deuxième chose je le rappelais tout à
l'heure il y a effectivement les mesures
de solidarité pour s'assurer que nous
aurons tous ce qu'il faut cet hiver et
de diversification des
approvisionnements et aujourd'hui les
discussions qui sont à l'oeuvre elles
concernent effectivement directement la
baisse des prix donc il y a plusieurs
façons de faire ça et toutes ces façons
et ses options sont à l'étude d'où la
confusion que certains ont pu soulever
parfois on peut mettre des plafonds sur
les prix du gaz importer de Russie nous
l'avons fait sur le pétrole nous pouvons
le faire avec eux des corridors ça veut
dire que au lieu de mettre un prix fixe
on va se situer dans une ligne parce
qu'évidemment tout le monde n'a pas les
mêmes contrats européens nous pouvons
faire la même chose discuter la même
chose avec la Norvège mais aussi avec
d'autres fournisseurs tels que les
États-Unis dans la mesure où nous aurons
des prix qui seront suffisants pour
toujours attirer du gaz et notamment du
gaz naturel liquéfié en Europe puisque
la concurrence avec l'Asie comme vous le
savez va être forte donc ça c'est sur
les plafonds sur les prix du gaz importé
on peut également mettre des plafonds
sur les prix de gros dans l'Union
européenne à nouveau pour faire baisser
les prix du gaz évidemment ça ça va
demander des subventions puis il y a le
troisième sujet qui est celui qui est
connu sous le nom du de mécanisme
ibérique dans lequel on baisse le prix
du gaz par rapport au prix de marché
grâce à une subvention d'État et donc le
prix d'électricité fabriquée à partir de
ce gaz baisse naturellement ça n'aurait
pas beaucoup d'intérêt de le faire en
France uniquement ce que nous produisons
très peu d'électricité à partir de gaz
comme vous le savez c'est pour ça que
nous portons une solution en européen
qui aurait l'avantage de faire baisser
les prix pour tous les Européens et donc
éventuellement aussi les prix de
l'électricité que nous importons
pardonnez-moi je lis dans les yeux du
cinéma que j'étais un peu longue sur ce
sujet
merci
donc voilà pour cette question sur les
prix de l'énergie et enfin vous m'avez
posé la question
sur l'Iran comme je viens de le répondre
au sénateur
aussi nature lourd nous sommes en train
de prendre des mesures elles seront
décidées au Conseil des affaires
étrangères le 17 octobre et la ministre
l'a rappelé ce matin sur France Inter de
façon très claire au cas où vous ne
l'auriez pas entendu
monsieur le sénateur gâteau lin je vous
remercie d'avoir noté le réveil
géopolitique de l'Europe je suis
en fait on devrait mettre vous savez
dans les organisations internationales
on met des plaques avec les noms ça
serait tellement bien je vous prie de
m'excuser oui
dans une petite maison où tout le monde
se connaît donc je ne doute pas que
absolument
un verre à tous pour pouvoir faire
faites pas ce matin
alors mais je vous remercie et je vous
remercie pour ça
c'est j'ai vraiment j'ai trouvé que je
vous remercie d'avoir résumé ce passage
de l'économie à la géopolitique de la
voir aussi bien expliqué y compris avec
cette magnifique citation de Jacques
Delors c'est vrai je crois vraiment
qu'il y a
un réveil géopolitique est important ici
d'ailleurs le sens de la communauté
politique européenne puisque tous les
pays qui sont dedans n'ont pas vocation
à être candidats et pour certains nous
savons que ce sera long c'est très
important
de comprendre
à quel point pour les autres pays être
vu dans cette communauté politique et
avoir leur chef de l'État et
gouvernement réunis ensemble parlant
d'égal à égal avec les chefs d'État et
gouvernement de Union européenne veut
dire quelque chose politiquement et nous
les et les attache à l'esprit européen
et c'est d'autant plus important
évidemment que tout le monde ne sera pas
candidat et que nous préférons bien
évidemment que tous ces pays du
voisinage tombent dans notre sphère
d'influence celle de la démocratie de
l'État droit des droits de l'homme on
fait tout ce que vous avez rappelé
plutôt que la sphère d'influence de pays
qui ont tendance à ne pas respecter ses
droits et c'est vrai aussi que l'image
politique est forte mais la politique a
besoin de s'appuyer sur des coopérations
concrètes d'où les 7 champs que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure
je crois aussi et c'était le sens de ce
que j'essayais de rappeler dans le
propos liminaire que ce réveil
géopolitique se voit aussi dans
l'évolution de la stratégie avec la
Chine et du débat qui aura lieu dans les
prochaines semaines là-dessus
sur la défense
et en fait c'est très intéressant la
façon dont tout le monde présente les
choses bien sûr et en particulier ce que
vous disiez je crois que pour pour que
l'Europe soit forte il faut
effectivement qu'elle ait une stratégie
géopolitique une stratégie défense une
stratégie industrielle d'où le sens de
tout ce qui est fait sur l'autonomie et
notamment énergétique comme vous l'avez
mentionné et puis cette cette promenade
c'est important ce que l'on donne à
l'état de droit sur la défense j'ai
démissionné la boussole l'articulation
avec le temps va être importante parce
que c'est vrai et vous avez été
plusieurs à le dire certains pays de
l'Est achètent du matériel américain et
nous voulons absolument favoriser les
achats de matériel européen non
seulement parce que c'est une question
de commerce extérieur mais c'est
également une question stratégique
puisque ça veut dire de la recherche
chez nous et de la technologie produite
en européenne et puis construire aussi
quelque chose de plus solide c'est vrai
vous l'avez noté
on a besoin de plus investissements des
pays européens dans la défense
la période bénie des dividendes de la
paix et derrière nous et d'ailleurs des
pays comme la Finlande ou la Suède qui
ont demandé leur adhésion à l'OTAN vont
devoir faire un effort significatif
d'investissement notamment capacités
mais aussi humain pour pour atteindre ce
que demande l'OTAN et enfin sur
l'autonomie énergétique je crois que
nous sommes totalement d'accord elle est
essentielle
à la fois pour assurer notre sécurité
celle de nos entreprises et la
protection des citoyens et pour des
carbonner nos économies et je pense que
de ce point de vue à la fois le paquet
européen et la stratégie plus
spécifiquement française est excellente
puisqu'elle va nous garantir rapidement
une autonomie et une sécurité
énergétique
monsieur le sénateur gueriau je vois que
je vois dans mes notes que vous avez
également
parlé de cette question de
cette question des prix
énergétique et ça me permet de vous
rappeler que j'ai effectivement pas
mentionné la plateforme d'achat que vous
avez mentionné
qui certes créer des sujets à la fois de
concurrence et de réalocation en
concurrence il y a des moyens en Europe
et en discutant avec la commission de
que les étapes puissent en fait donner
charge à des entreprises d'acheter pour
le compte de la communauté et ensuite
effectivement il y a un sujet de
réallocation mais qui est déjà lui aussi
à l'oeuvre alors ça fait partie des
moyens envisagés ça nous donne un
pouvoir de marché je pense que c'est
important et nous allons le pousser en
fait nous poussons toutes les options
qui vont permettre de faire baisser les
prix
j'ai on verra si on y arrive aussi vite
que la semaine prochaine puisqu'on parle
déjà de la semaine prochaine mais on
sait en tant que le cas quelque chose
qui est important à la fois pour les
flux de ce que l'on achète mais ça peut
aussi être envisagé pour la constitution
de stock donc on regarde aussi ceci
c'est vrai qu'il reste du travail vous
l'avez souligné c'est vrai que parfois
nous avons pu être frustré et comme je
le disais tout à l'heure la ministre
Agnès et le ministre Bruno Le Maire ont
poussé depuis février le fait de
réformer le marché d'électricité nous en
avons reparlé en juillet mais là je
crois que le monde a été très clair et
la présidente de la commission en a
parlé dans une lettre et en a parlé au
chef d'État et de gouvernement
vendredi il y a deux sujets j'ai j'en
profite puisque je sais que c'est une
question qui intéresse beaucoup plus de
personnes il y a deux sujets à cet égard
il y a le sujet immédiat qui est celui
du mécanisme ibérique que j'ai mentionné
donc qui permet effectivement de là où
on plafonne le prix du gaz qui est
utilisé pour l'électricité et puis il y
a un sujet de moyen terme qui est d'une
réforme pérenne ni durable du marché de
l'électricité on l'a vu on a eu un
système qui a fonctionné pendant 20 ans
qui ne fonctionne plus aujourd'hui et
donc il est temps de le revoir
pour
dans vos questions vous me permettez je
crois de
de répondre de donner de précision
notamment lorsque vous avez parlé de
l'annonce des 200 milliards de
l'Allemagne après je dois le rappeler
que la France fait 100 milliards sur sur
la même période
si nous faisons
ce mécanisme
ibérique effectivement c'était en
européen c'est un mécanisme de
solidarité où il faudra qu'il y a
quelques transferts oui absolument mais
comme vous savez ils sont dans un dans
un îlot énergétique et c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont pu le faire plus vite il y a
aussi la question du prix du gaz auquel
ils l'ont fixé puisqu'il a consommation
de gaz n'a pas baissé en Allemagne en
Espagne pardon en partie parce qu'il y a
une sécheresse cet été donc évidemment
il y a moins de production
hydroélectrique il va être important de
trouver le bon prix et je crois que
c'est
un autre de vos collègues qui a posé la
question à des 180 mégawh il va être
important de trouver le bon prix
d'équilibre entre protéger les
consommateurs et les entreprises mais ne
pas inciter à la consommation il est
quand même essentiel qu'on continue de
baisser c'est de consommation et que
surtout en face des des économies
d'énergie il va falloir qu'on trouve un
mécanisme de solidarité réfléchi entre
européen parce qu'évidemment certains
pays vont bénéficier de cette mesure
beaucoup plus que d'autres de par leur
mécanismes énergétique mais tout le
monde va baisser de va bénéficier de la
baisse des prix puisque nous avons un
marché
commun donc ça ça va être important
si ça annonce allemand aussi été mais
c'était un petit peu ce qui s'était
passé pendant le covid l'occasion de
rappeler que tout le monde n'a pas la
même capacité budgétaire et que ce choc
qui est le même choc qui s'adresse à
l'ensemble des pays à des effets qui
sont asymétriques pour chacun des pays
et donc la présidente de la commission
l'a annoncé les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement lui ont demandé de se
pencher sur ce sujet pour pouvoir faire
des choses le vin ou 21 octobre il va
falloir des mécanismes de solidarité
pour certains pays qui n'ont pas les
mêmes capacités à protéger et leur
consommateurs et leurs entreprises et
donc vous avez entendu parler des
différentes options qui sont sur la
table qui concernent un je suis désolé
ils ne l'ont pas traduit en français
ripower INEX generation you et
éventuellement les autres mécanismes qui
avaient été mis en place
pendant la gestion de la crise covid et
qui pourrait être adapté pour celles de
la crise énergétique
sur l'autonomie stratégique en matière
d'énergie j'espère que j'ai en répondant
à votre à votre collègue au sénateur
notamment gâteau linge j'ai répondu oui
d'accord et sur l'alimentaire je crois
que vous avez raison de soulever la
question
la stratégie ferme tout fort son
adaptation pendant la crise du covid et
le sommet uafrique vise effectivement à
assurer de la sécurité énergétique
aujourd'hui aussi avec les corridors
humanitaires qui ont été mis en place
mais aussi de façon durable chez nous et
en Afrique parce que c'est aussi la
d'abord en soi c'est important et c'est
aussi la condition pour une Afrique qui
peut se développer et croître et assurer
son autonomie elle-même ce qui
évidemment indispensable et nécessaire
monsieur le sénateur
corbiset et je vous remercie d'avoir
[Musique]
posé les questions sur les militaires et
souligner comme vous l'avez fait que
effectivement
le
Danemark a accepté de participer à
l'effort
pour soutenir l'Ukraine en renonçant au
César qui devait lui être livré et de
les réorienter vers l'Ukraine ce qui est
effectivement comme ils étaient
immédiatement disponibles disponible
pardon permet d'assurer à une réponse
plus rapide de soutien en la matière à
l'Ukraine donc merci d'avoir mentionné
cela
sur les prélèvements des stocks et de
l'Union européenne la raison notamment
pour laquelle je mentionnais la facilité
européenne de la paix c'est parce
qu'elle permet de renouveler
ses stocks nous avons aussi enfin
l'Union européenne s'apprête aussi à se
douter d'un fond d'urgence de près de
500 millions d'euros qui visent
directement à reconstituer nos stocks
d'équipements militaires et de munitions
c'est un règlement qui est en cours de
négociation et qui nous espérons sera
adoptée d'ici à la fin de l'année et
évidemment comme je l'ai mentionné tout
à l'heure nous veillerons à ce qu'il
bénéficie en priorité aux industries
européennes
ça serait mieux c'est pas toujours le
cas
sur le plafond du prix du gaz et du
découplage j'espère que les réponses que
j'ai apportées aussiateur guerriot vous
vous vont également
merci et donc je vais parler je vais
passer
au sénateur faire je Michel
sénateur corbisé j'espère que j'ai
répondu à toutes vos questions avant
merci
vous avez émotionné l'État de droit
monsieur verniquer et vous savez à quel
point c'est important pour nous
j'ai peut-être même parfois trop parler
de cela à nouveau il y a deux procédures
en cours mais on sera très vigilant en
européen je voudrais juste rajouter ici
d'ailleurs que la Commission européenne
comme vous savez et si je ne me trompe
pas et c'est le commissariat se font un
rapport chaque année sur l'état de droit
dans les 27 pays de l'Union européenne
accordée de recommandations que bien
évidemment nous en France prenons aussi
très au sérieux
vous avez mentionné l'inflation et
notamment l'énergie et les questions
économiques et ce qui me donne
l'occasion de rappeler que la moitié de
cette inflation en européen vient des
prix de l'énergie qui ont augmenté
considérablement et effectivement
directement causé par la Russie et
Vladimir Poutine en juin avec ses prix
d'énergie mais qui avait quand même un
peu augmenté
avant maintenant l'inflation alimentaire
contribue à peu près 20% de l'inflation
totale c'est vrai c'est beaucoup ça
touche beaucoup de nos concitoyens d'où
les boucliers à la fois énergétiques et
les mesures pour protéger l'alimentation
et les ménages les plus vulnérables en
particulier que vous avez mentionné je
crois que vous avez également mentionné
le pack de stabilité et de croissance
et comme je le disais dans nos propos
liminaire pour nous il y a trois choses
qui sont importantes à la soutenabilité
des finances publiques à moyen terme
bien sûr de préserver la croissance avec
des investissements productifs et de
permettre la double transition numérique
et écologique tout au long des années
qui viennent je crois que l'avancée
nous aurons effectivement des
propositions fin octobre mais je crois
qu'une certaine mesure ou certaines
états d'esprit auxquels nous sommes très
attachés c'est effectivement de pouvoir
discuter avec la Commission et le
Conseil bien sûr pour avoir la
trajectoire budgétaire qui soit
approprié en regard des investissements
qui sont nécessaires à la fois dans
l'appareil productif mais aussi dans
cette transition énergétique c'est
important parce que ça permettra une
meilleure appropriation effectivement à
plus en grand engagement du gouvernement
et de l'exécutif et donc une plus grande
responsabilité donc à la fois on atteint
nos objectifs qui sont économiques
écologiques numériques mais aussi de
soutenabilité des finances publiques qui
sont importants comme nous le savons
vous m'avez
et donc j'espère que cela répond à votre
question sur l'importance de
l'environnement dans le dans les règles
budgétaires vous m'avez également
interrogé sur
la scène et l'amendement qui qui
remettait en cause et un consensus qui
est très fragile entre les États on
aurait dû adopter
si on avait permis cet amendement on
aurait remis en cause l'ensemble du
texte qui n'aurait pas du tout pu être
adopté et avec le risque des États
étrangers puissent venir pêcher dans nos
dans nos eaux avec des navires
industriels et c'est vraiment ça qu'on a
cherché à éviter en rejetant en
acceptant pas cette amendement
c'est juste une petite intervention sur
cette histoire de la scène de la scène
des mersal ça vous permet de faire une
petite pause madame la ministre il y a
quand même un grand paradoxe entre le
fait que finalement la scène des mersal
soit soutenue par le gouvernement quand
même temps on annonce le plan de sortie
de flotte et donc que de là on considère
que la pêche artisanale se termine moi
je l'entends enfin voilà les signaux
sont là et sur les questions de pêche on
pourrait me dire tout ce que vous voulez
c'est des questions que je suis depuis
30 ans j'ai vu les évolutions arriver
j'ai vu les la baisse des tonnages se
faire et arriver dans les ports donc je
pense que les signaux qui sont donnés là
aujourd'hui sont claires
je ne dis pas que la pêche des mersal
est quelque chose à écarter complètement
mais aujourd'hui le soutien affiché sur
cette technique de pêche fait que on a
des messages qui sont paradoxaux et qui
sont compliqués à accepter sur le sur le
terrain voilà c'est simplement une
remarque
pas de réponse immédiate mais je vous
apporte
l'éclair je ne sais pas si on doit
éclairer un ministre mais je vous
apporte au moins le
visage de ce que ce qui est vécu sur mon
territoire et au contact des pêcheurs
tous les jours moi la pêche c'est une
heure de travail par jour quoi avec les
avec les instances professionnelles
bien sûr le sénateur doit éclairer le
ministre précisément parce qu'il est au
compte comme vous le disiez au contact
oui et nous y prêterons beaucoup
d'attention je vais juste dire une chose
sur
en fait la flotte à laquelle on mesure
sur les flottes laquelle vous faisiez
allusion et c'est mesures qui permettent
à des pêcheurs effectivement d'arrêter
de pêcher et de recevoir une
compensation pour cela le nombre est a
priori très petit je pense qu'il y en a
peu qui sous votre contrôle qui vont se
saisir de ça et c'est vrai qu'il y a une
transformation de la pêche comme de
l'agriculture sur lequel on pourra bien
sûr revenir mais je voudrais pas
enquêter sur les territoires de dervé
Berville mais sachez que
merci et sachez que pour le brexit je
crois que la France c'est admirablement
battu sur les conséquences que ça
pouvait avoir sur les pêcheurs et
j'espère que puisque vous mentionnez les
licences monsieur le sénateur et vous
pouvez compter sur nous
mais même si ça représente un nombre
infime madame la ministre ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'on est dans des signaux
quoi c'est la aussi la question de la
confiance que que les pêcheurs remettent
en particulier les pêcheurs artisans
artisanaux on a cette flotte qui
finalement s'étiole au fil du temps et
je pense que c'est une réalité à
constater c'est bien sûr le domaine
d'Hervé Berville
je pense qu'il vous apporte aussi au
titre des affaires européens vous avez
raison et nous nous parlons beaucoup et
peut-être qu'on pourra se reparler une
fois où il est réellement
sur le terrain
le
ce qui m'amène je crois
et si monsieur le sénateur Ferney qui me
autorise à un passé aux réponses que je
dois
sénateur Pierre Laurent
alors vous m'avez parlé
de puisque je vais reprendre votre
expression vous m'avez parlé des super
profils ou pour que qui s'appelle
effectivement en langage européen qui
est décidé à 27 comme vous savez la
contribution est temporaire
exceptionnelle qui est de
33% sur les entreprises de production et
de production à base d'hydrocarbures et
de raffinage alors les estimations que
vous citez elles sont au niveau européen
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure dans mon
propos liminaire la France appliquera
cette contribution ce sera dans le
projet de loi de finances 2023 et les
chiffres seront dans le projet de loi de
finances 2023 je ne peux pas vous les
donner ce matin
vous m'avez ensuite interroger sur la
déco relation du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité oui effectivement c'est à
l'ordre du jour de deux façons
c'est à l'ordre du jour à la fois à
travers le mécanisme
ibérique dans tous nos discussions tout
à l'heure en européen ou on fixerait un
prix de enfin là pour le coup c'est pas
vraiment une décoller sur mon
frictionnelle prix du gaz à court terme
pour faire baisser le prix d'électricité
la décorrélation au sens propre c'est la
revue comme vous savez du marché de
l'électricité pour laquelle ce que nous
ce que nous espérons et c'est à quoi la
Commission est engagée c'est de donner
des premières pistes d'ici à la fin de
l'année donc cette réforme de moyen
terme elle est à l'étude et nous vous
tiendrons bien sûr au courant de ce qui
est de ce qui est proposé à nouveau je
le rappelle le gouvernement français le
porte depuis février ou mars 2022
le
180 mégawattheure c'est une excellente
question c'est une indication elle
pourra être et nous souhaitons qu'elle
soit moduler par technologie par exemple
parce que on n'a pas les mêmes coups de
production que ce soit à partir d'une
nucléaire ou de ou de photosvoltaïques
ou autre
et donc il y a un arbitrage qui est en
cours avec des discussions qui est en
cours et à nouveau j'ai manquerai pas de
vous revenir mais je pense que cet
arbitrage sera aussi dans le projet de
loi de finance
ce que je voudrais juste ajouter c'est à
nouveau
vous renouveler le fait que ce que
vraiment nous portons c'est de faire
baisser les prix de faire baisser les
prix sans mettre en danger la transition
énergétique parce que on évidemment le
voit pas mais pour reprendre
des propos la crainte qu'on ait c'est
qu'effectivement ça suscite de
l'inquiétude sur le coût de la
transition énergétique et ce qu'on
voudrait aujourd'hui c'est arriver
évidemment à la fois avoir des énergies
à des prix raisonnables et qui soit
décarbonée donc toutes les options que
la Commission met sur la table pour
faire baisser les prix nous soutenons
nos étudiants nous intervisions avec
elle et tous les conseils qui seront
nécessaires pour faire cela la France il
sera
je crois
je crois monsieur le Président que j'ai
il me reste pardon une question
qu'effectivement sur les ressources
propres absolument de Jean-François
Husson
et comme vous le savez nous y sommes
favorables non seulement sur le plan
financier puisque c'est puisque c'est la
manière de financer les ambitions
européennes sans eux aussi des
contributions nationales et j'ai entendu
est-ce que tu dis c'est le rapporteur
général mais surtout ça va nous
permettre de mieux aligner le mode de
financement du budget de l'Union sur nos
grandes priorités politiques et aussi de
sortir de cette logique de retour entre
contributeurs et bénéficiaires net qui
je crois de lui à la bonne qualité de la
discussion et la solidarité européenne
merci
merci Madame ministre d'avoir été précis
il y a des sujets effectivement qui
nécessitent plus de d'attention que
d'autres en ce moment notamment
l'énergie vous y êtes arrêté je vous en
cette fois-ci
on va suivre de près bien sûr
l'évolution
de rondeurs comme vous l'avez dit parce
que l'évolution incertaine qu'il y a à
la fois le contexte énergétique mais
aussi la guerre en Ukraine sont très
mouvantes sont très mouvantes alors ce
que je vous propose mes chers collègues
j'ai 4 demandes de questions donc on
pourrait séparer deux et deux et madame
la ministre pourra répondre ce que je
vous demande c'est d'être rapide une
minute trente pas plus de deux minutes
en tout cas pour poser vos questions à
Madame la Ministre donc je vais demander
à Madame grunier et Martha Sidrac
merci monsieur le Président même la
ministre mes chers collègues
nous établissons
là très vite un rapport sur l'Europe du
médicament avec ma collègue Laurence
arribé donc j'ai deux questions courtes
sur sur le médicament donc tout d'abord
la Commission européenne elle prépare
une révision de la législation
pharmaceutique qui dessinait améliorer
la gestion des ruptures
d'approvisionnement en médicaments qu'un
sujet aussi assez important prévenant un
dialogue structuré est actuellement en
cours et qui implique des représentants
de l'industrie et des patients les États
membres ont été faire des propositions
pouvez-vous nous dire comment la France
a été impliquée dans ce processus et
quelle position le gouvernement français
a-t-il soutenu
et la Commission européenne a présenté
aussi une proposition de règlement qui
vise à créer un espace européen de des
données de santé cette proposition fait
débat au sein du conseil sur ce sujet
pouvez-vous me confirmer que Microsoft
sera en charge du stockage des données
et le recours à des solutions techniques
gérées par des opérateurs
extra-européens ne présente-t-il pas un
risque pour la sécurité de ces données
merci beaucoup
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre l'été a été marqué
effectivement par une flambée des prises
la a été rappelé à plusieurs reprises
l'hiver s'annonce sous le signe de la
sobriété énergétique cette situation
contribue à alléger malheureusement
substantiellement le porte-monnaie des
Européens des Français en général et qui
subissent en fait une grande partie ces
restrictions en raison de l'agression de
l'Ukraine par la Russie et cela nous
pose aussi beaucoup de difficultés
d'approvisionnement cela a été rappelé
bien sûr il est essentiel et vous l'avez
très bien rappelé collègues l'ont
rappelé il faut soutenir aujourd'hui nos
partenaires européens dans les sanctions
vis-à-vis de la Russie mais cela ne nous
dispense pas malgré tout de nous
interroger sur les approvisionnements de
substitution que nous avons trouvé en
cette période nous achetons à prix d'or
du pétrole à l'Arabie Saoudite et du gaz
à Lazare et beijan l'Arabie Saoudite ne
brille pas beaucoup en matière d'égalité
je pense aux femmes saoudiennes madame
la ministre et lazarebaïdjan aujourd'hui
attaquent et agressent un État souverain
madame la ministre que pouvez-vous nous
dire quand au choix de ses partenaires
commerciaux envisagez-vous d'aborder ce
sujet au prochain conseil
personnellement je pense qu'il y va de
la crédibilité de l'Europe et cela
étailler également à l'occasion des
différentes questions qui vous ont été
posées du respect de ces valeurs
fondamentales je vous remercie
merci Madame la vice-présidente pour
votre question sur l'Europe du
médicament et
sur les données sur la révision de la
législation pharmaceutique en matière de
la gestion des ruptures
d'approvisionnement médicament comme
vous savez c'est
quelque chose auquel nous attachons
beaucoup d'importance notamment pour
renforcer notre notre autonomie
stratégique mais en européen à nouveau
alors la révision de cette législation
ne doit être présentée par la Commission
en décembre cette année nous n'avons pas
encore de détails de précision sur les
mesures qui seront dans la proposition
de la Commission ce que je peux vous
dire à ce stade c'est que les services
du ministère de la Santé ont été
impliqués ces derniers mois dans les
travaux préparatoires et que bien
évidemment ils suivent les
développements du sujet et ces
implications et dès que la Commission
aura fait une proposition nous allons
suivre et participer aux travaux sur le
projet de législation et bien sûr je
suis à votre disposition à ce moment-là
pour pour en discuter plus en détail sur
la question des données c'est également
en cours de discussion donc là c'est une
question de savoir qui sera en charge de
libéralement des données n'est pas
précisé dans le texte à ce stade le
contrôleur européen de la protection des
données et le Comité européen de la
protection des données ont tous les deux
produits un avis sur la question parce
qu'il considère justement que le texte
est trop silencieux sur ce point comme
comme vous le soulignez et normalement
la vie qui
qu'il recommande c'est que ce soit
inscrit dans le dans le texte que ces
données doivent être hébergées sur le
territoire de l'Union Européenne
donc nous et comme l'Union européenne je
crois que nous serons très vigilants sur
les risques en matière de
confidentialité on a encore vu
réservement des attaques cybers sur les
hôpitaux et évidemment vous pouvez
compter sur notre engagement et notre
mobilisation sur ce sujet
madame de Sidrac vous avez soulevé la
question de
l'Azerbaïdjan et l'Arabie Saoudite avec
avec raison c'est toujours extrêmement
délicat et la première chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que chaque fois
qu'il y a des discussions bilatérales
avec un de ces pays comme avec d'autres
nous rappelons le sujet des droits de
l'homme nous sommes très fermes sur sur
les demandes que nous faisons en matière
de respect aussi des droits de la femme
des droits de la famille comme ce qui
est en train de se passer avec l'Iran
ça demande un dialogue permanent comme
vous savez le président de la République
qui a passé avec Charles Michel près de
4 heures pour arriver à négocier un
accord entre l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan
pour pouvoir avoir une mission de
l'Union européenne sur les territoires
donc effectivement la diversification de
nos ressources énergétiques ne n'exclut
pas du tout et bien au contraire nous
oblige à être encore plus vigilant sur
les droits de l'homme sur les droits des
femmes sur ce qui se passe dans ces
territoires et vous pourrez compter sur
nous je finirai en disant que c'est pour
ça qu'il est urgent vraiment
urgent et important de sortir des
hydrocarbures fossiles aussi
parce que ça c'est aussi une forme de
pression pour pousser les pays à se
diversifier et puis à respecter les
droits qui fondamentaux qui sont su de
tout de tous les êtres humains et
j'ajouterai en conclusion que sur tout
ce qui est devoir de vigilance nous
allons également être nous aussi très
vigilants pour s'assurer que que les
droits elles sont respectés notamment
les droits des enfants vous avez vu je
crois que l'Union européenne est en
train de monter en puissance là-dessus
on en a assez peu parlé mais la Chine
par exemple nous ne signons pas d'accord
d'investissement avec la Chine tant que
la question des Ouigours et du travail
forcé n'est pas résolu merci
merci alors deux autres questions
dans l'ordre pierre aux olias et puis
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre je voudrais à mon tour
soutenir la ce que le fort propos de la
présidente Martha de Sidrac en rappelant
que le voile dit islamiste il est
l'instrument de la domination masculine
dans toutes les théocraties qu'elle nous
fournit sous pas du pétrole
et je pense que et ça renvoie un débat
en ce moment sur l'Europe je crois qu'à
un moment donné la mélisse il faut dire
les choses c'est pas comme certains le
disent un détail vestimentaire c'est
quelque chose de fondamental qui qui
nous engage nous Européens de façon
forte vous vous avez parlé du conflit
entre
l'Azerbaïdjan et l'Arménie
dans des termes qui m'ont choqué il
s'agit pas des droits de l'homme les
frontières internationales de l'Arménie
sont reconnus par l'ONU et c'est
l'Azerbaïdjan qui a agressé ce pays de
la même façon que la Russie a agressé
l'Ukraine et nous a mis Arménie j'étais
en Arménie il y a 15 jours ne
comprennent pas comment nous pouvons
être aussi ferme
vis-à-vis de la l'Ukraine et aujourd'hui
laissez tomber l'Arménie dont on sait
très bien que son sort risque d'être une
reproduction malheureuse du génocide de
1915 le problème il est il est là moi
j'ai rencontré un gouvard moment
arménien en pleurs madame la ministre
ampleur ils avaient le sentiment qui ne
pourrait pas éviter à leur peuple un
second génocide nous en sommes là et
dans le même temps la présidente de la
Commission européenne va à bas coût en
disant que l'Azerbaïdjan est un
partenaire fiable avec lequel il faut
passer des contrats gazés pétroliers et
au-delà et au-delà voilà je ne comprends
pas comment au sein de l'Europe la
parole forte du président de la
République qui alors que la France
préside le Conseil de sécurité a désigné
l'agresseur l'Azerbaïdjan puisse trouver
sa position fragilisée par
la position de la présidente de la
Commission européenne il faut le dire
très clairement et j'en finirai là
l'effondrement militaire de la Russie en
Ukraine que je constate je ne le
regrette pas aura des répercussions
majeures dans le Caucase le problème des
nationalités n'est pas réglée ni au sein
de la fédération la Russie et encore
moins dans le Caucase du Sud il faut que
Madame la Ministre la France parle de
façon très claire ce qui est en jeu
c'est l'existence même de l'Arménie
merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le 26
septembre dernier les radars sismiques
des réseaux de surveillance suédoises
danois ont enregistré deux explosions
autour de l'île danoise de bornelm à la
suite de quoi vous le savez quatre
fuites ont été détectés sur les deux
gazoducs sous-marin Nord Stream 2
reliant la Russie à l'Allemagne avec
chacun environ à peu près 150 millions
de mètres cubes dans chacun des gazeux
ducs selon les termes employés par
l'OTAN il s'agirait d'acte de sabotage
délibéré donc tous les regards se sont
tournés vers la Russie qui elle de son
côté dénoncent un acte de terrorisme
international et pointe à demi-mot les
États-Unis
là j'en viens au cœur de mon propos
madame la ministre aujourd'hui le
sabotage des gazoducs meurent stream
revient une dimension nouvelle qui nous
alerte sur la protection impérative de
nos infrastructures stratégiques
énergétiques de communication également
sous-marine et extra atmosphérique dans
un contexte de Guerry bride le président
de la République lui-même considère à
juste titre que nos infrastructures
essentielles énergétiques et de
communication câble sous-marin et
satellite hors du territoire national
sont des éléments de vulnérabilité que
nous devons renforcer et défendre selon
ses propos
aussi madame la ministre et dans le
cadre du prochain Conseil européen
comment la France entend-elle participé
aux côtés de l'Europe au renforcement et
à la protection de nos infrastructures
énergétiques et stratégiques européennes
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur sénateurs
[Musique]
enfin en 3 ans plus tôt
la première chose
sur vous avez parlé de l'Iran et de voir
l'islamiques à nouveau je le répète très
tôt j'ai avec mes collègues
effectivement exprimer tout mon soutien
aux femmes iraniennes qui enlèvent leurs
voiles pour protester contre lassassinat
de Masha
avec le ministre général d'ArmA et
Darmanin et la ministre Catherine
Colonna quand il s'était agit de
l'association femisso nous avons écrit à
la Commission européenne et j'ai même
apporté en main propre à la commissaire
européenne en charge des documents
montrant qu'il ait il ne fallait pas
promouvoir cette association donc comme
vous le voyez nous agissons sur le voile
les émotionné tout à l'heure les
sanctions qui sont en discussion au
Conseil des affaires étrangères le 17
octobre sur l'Arménie l'Azerbaïdjan
j'étais également avec le président de
la République quand il a passé quatre
heures avec le président avec les deux
chefs d'État et de gouvernement de ces
pays
et la France je voulais
je voulais dit je l'espère et clairement
répondant à d'autres questions et
solidaire de l'Arménie face au violation
inacceptable de son intégrité
territoriale elle s'est mobilisée et je
parle toujours de la France pour
stabiliser la situation sur le terrain
pour demander le retour des forces
azerbaïdjanais sur leur position
initiale et pour accompagner la reprise
des négociations entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan ce sommet quadrilatéral
que je viens de mentionner qui était en
marche du premier sommet de la
communauté poétique européenne qui
souligne également l'intérêt de cette
communauté
a notamment permis un accord sur la mise
en place sur le territoire arménien
d'une mission civile de l'Union
européenne pour une durée deux mois le
long de la frontière avec l'Azerbaïdjan
qui qui l'a accepté accepté de coopérer
alors vous allez me demander quel est
l'objectif de cette mission
il est double à établir
[Musique]
autant que possible une relation de
confiance dans les pour faciliter des
discussions entre les deux parties et
puis également stabiliser la situation à
la frontière et évidemment l'ambition
pour la suite par la suite pour cette
mission c'est de contribuer vous le
savez il y a un comité de qui se discute
de la frontière entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan et de contribuer les
variations utiles pour pour ces
discussions là
le périmètre et les moyens de la mission
sont actuellement en discours de
discussion à Bruxelles nous à titre
national nous souhaitons que ça aille le
plus vite possible et
je voudrais juste ajouter que c'était
des décisions c'était des discussions
très dures très courageux de la part des
responsables Arméniens et que je
comprends tout à fait ce que ce que vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure
en ce qui concerne alors monsieur le
sénateur là et je m'aperçois que je
Ludovic est oui pardon je m'aperçois que
je ne trouve pas
je vais vous demander de répéter votre
question que je n'ai pas bien noté voilà
pas de problème j'ai juste à avoir après
des propos liminaires sous les attaques
sur les gazoducs je voulais voilà je
voulais simplement vous alerter par
rapport à votre prochain Conseil
européen sur sur la façon dont la France
entend participer au côté de l'Europe au
renforcement et à la protection des
infrastructures énergétiques et
stratégiques européennes merci je vous
en prie pardonnez-moi et d'avoir un
corps chez votre nom et d'avoir oublié
cette question c'est un peu bouleversé
par
[Musique]
en Ukraine donc absolument je pense que
ce sera au Conseil européen et je ne
manquerai pas de vous revenir sur le
contenu de ces de ces discussions merci
de votre question
très bien merci Madame la Ministre on
est parfaitement dans dans les temps
pour les pour les réunions de groupe
merci de cet échange et puis nous en
aurons un autre après le Conseil
européen
au format commission et on verra si
d'ici là la situation a évolué merci en
tout cas de du temps passé
merci à vous monsieur le Président et
bien sûr je suis à votre disposition si
la situation évolue d'ici là et que vous
l'estimez nécessaire vous pouvez compter
sur moi